thank you
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast I have the pleasure of sitting
with my good friends Amy and Devin James
who are co-executive directors of the
web 3 working group which is a 501c3
they know things I've been talking to
them for years about questions
surrounding uh the security and
functioning of the web and I'm going to
persuade them to speak as much in
English as possible in talking about
where we are headed and uh what internet
it is we will face once we get there Amy
and Devin welcome to Darkhorse
hi Brett it's okay
it's so good thank you great to see you
Brett yeah it's great to see you guys
um
it has been a long journey behind the
scenes
where we have checked in regularly about
uh issues of Safety and Security on the
web uh issues of the wow I can't use the
term Equitable anymore but the way that
the web distributes content and pays
creators all sorts of issues that are
increasingly Central to this mechanism
we all use to interface so what I'm
hoping you guys will do is talk to us
about the current state of the web about
web3 I'm hoping you will Define that
term and we can explore questions about
how this interfaces with the various
hazards and opportunities provided by
artificial intelligence
um anyway let's let's start with that
what can you tell us about web 3 what is
it and uh what should we do to make it
better
to get started
get stuck about how we got to web3 so
web one began when sir Tim berners-lee
introduced the web protocol in 1989 1990
um and before that we had access to the
internet via
proprietary Stacks so you could get on
with compuster you could get on with AOL
but if you were on CompuServe and I was
on AOL we didn't see the same content
and we couldn't interact with each other
because these were closed proprietary
stacks and the web was this way that all
of the information could get connected
and it gave us this open space and it
was super exciting and it's obviously
grown hugely in the last
20 30 years and
um so then it was it was actually
intended well it was decentralized right
at the beginning because literally
everyone would run their own web server
right and that code was all in plain
text English so anyone that wanted to
learn about it could just check the
source of one website that they liked
and write their own and put up a site on
geocity so it was very decentralized yes
exactly that was
one of the big changes when it came to
web 2 is that the infrastructure became
incredibly centralized so web one is
often considered the read-only web
because you needed sort of special
skills to be able to write content to it
like you needed to be able to host your
own server and to write your own web
page there weren't these kind of like
easy tools that we have today for user
generated content so web 2 began in
let's say the mid odds when YouTube
Facebook Myspace those kinds of
platforms were creating the tools that
users could write their own user
generated content to the web and so that
is thought of by people as the read
write web and then web 3 I don't know
when they're gonna pinpoint the exact
you know starting point of web 2 whether
it will be with the launch of Bitcoin
although I think that's probably too
early
um or if it's somewhere now because this
is really when like kind of the flurry
of activity in the building is happening
um but we're in the midst of it and web3
people call it the read write own web or
read write verify the idea there is that
there's this level of transparency and
sovereignty that web 2 didn't allow
because it was controlled by the what we
now call Big Tech
and so web3 gives us it it changes the
shape of the network back to a
decentralized shape it's pushing the
control back out to the ends of the
network to the user and that's because
of things like blockchain technology
um and and some other things but that's
the main one this episode is sponsored
by mud water that's mud wtr one of our
favorites mud water makes a fantastic
drink it's spicy and delicious and chock
full of adaptogenic mushrooms and
ayurvedic herbs with a seventh the
caffeine of a cup of coffee you get the
energy without the anxiety Jitters or
crash if you like the routine of making
something warm to drink in the morning
but don't drink coffee or trying to cut
down try mud water each ingredient in
mud water was added with intention it
has cacao and chai for just a hint of
caffeine lion's mane mushrooms to
support Focus cordyceps the good kind to
help support physical performance chaga
and Rishi to support your immune system
and cinnamon which is a potent
antioxidant in addition to tasting grade
mud water also makes a non-dairy creamer
out of coconut milk and MCT they also
make a sweetener out of coconut palm
sugar and lucuma a fruit of an Andean
tree used by the Inca to add if you
prefer those options or
you can mix and match add a bit of their
coconut milk and MCT creamer with some
honey from bees real bees or use mud
Waters lucuma and coconut palm sugar
sweetener and skip the bees entirely mud
water is also a hundred percent USDA
organic non-GMO gluten-free vegan and
kosher certified but water's flavor is
warm and spicy with a hint of chocolate
plus Masala chai which includes Ginger
and cardamom nutmeg and cloves it's also
delicious blended into a smoothie try it
with banana and Ice milk or milk-like
substance mint cacao nibs
and it's just the thing in the morning
to get 15 off go to
mudwtr.com
darkhorsepod to support the show use
Dark Horse pod for 15 off at checkout
all right so let me see if I understand
this and I should just say personally I
remember the first time I
became aware of the World Wide Web a
postdoc at Michigan where I was a
graduate student
was very excited he had just spent the
afternoon looking at the world wide web
and he pulled me into the I don't know
what it was a techno technology closet
it was a room with a couple of sun
workstations and he was you remember
about what year it was
it would have been
92. something like nice okay okay it was
pretty early
um he pulls me into this uh this Tech
closet and he sits me down in front of
the sun workstation he's like check this
out you can go anywhere
you know there were a couple of pages
and it was I couldn't let's just put it
this way it did not immediately dawn on
me that I was looking at a revolution in
the way information would be distributed
and I did go through a phase
where I put together a few crude web
pages Heather became more advanced at
putting together web pages but you know
it was as you say a read-only web for
most people you had to know a little bit
of HTML to even get anything to show up
on the web and if you didn't know a fair
amount of it it would show up badly
paginated and really ugly spread out to
the edge of the screen and all that yep
um
but you know okay so it was a place that
you could deposit things and people
could read it and it was decentralized
because anybody if you could get uh
somebody to host it you could put
anything up and then there was the era
of um you're calling it web 2 where you
had services that provided
um
mechanisms whereby you would be
interfacing with their HTML generator so
that you could put things up and it
would show up properly to your friends
but you weren't interfacing with the
back end but it required you to
interface with these services and now in
web 3 you're talking about
a decentralizing force and what's
confusing I suspect for many people is
why the authenticity question and the
decentralization question appear to be
the same right so a lot of people will
be vague on what blockchain exactly
means maybe you guys should start by
explaining what blockchain is and then
we can talk about how it interfaces with
the web component to make what you're
calling web3
well funny enough Amy was saying you
know it's hard to really say exactly
when when web3 began because Bitcoin
came out in 2009 but blockchain actually
came out the same year that the web did
or it was invented the same year one I
think around then you're right and it
was actually to solve uh it was a couple
of guys named Haber and sternetta that
wanted to solve for they ran into some
fraudulent biology papers
um and they wanted to be able to
basically say I want to have or really
what it was is they they saw that some
changes had been made something had been
published and then they made changes to
it and then they republished it and it
wasn't transparent that the changes had
been made and so they wanted to have a
database that was replicated enough
times where each copy of it was
identical to each other so that you
could actually see if anyone's trying to
make any alterations to things in their
case it still had a dependency on a
central point of failure there was no
way to because your computer's clock and
my computer's clock and the and various
web servers clock they might try to stay
in sync with each other but there's no
way to autonomously stay in sync without
trusting some Central source so there
was no way to time stamp them without
depending on a central Source they
solved that ultimately by literally they
would they would publish the some
aspects of the data literally into the
newspaper once a week and so that would
be the time stamp of it but it just kind
of it kept on running for years and
years and years and years but it always
had that central point of failure so
what it did have was it had full
replication where you would add a new
block and it would contain a bunch of
pieces of data and the block would
reference the previous block which means
in order to add a new block you need to
make sure that you have the exact same
history as every other node on the
network and so you can't make any
changes to previous blocks without it
being both transparent and rejected by
everyone else because you've made a
change so to just say it super simply a
blockchain is a public Ledger and so
when it comes to bitcoin it's a public
Ledger of money so for those of you that
remember you know the register in the
back of your checkbook kind of think of
it like that where it's just a log of
the transactions that have happened and
that the group of computers that are
verifying those transactions that they
all agree on all of those transactions
so they're publicly available and then
your other question was about did you
use the word autonomy or authenticity
authenticity yes the authenticity of
that comes from public key cryptography
and we can get into that kind of as a
second part of the conversation but
essentially that's just some math well
but the other the other important thing
about what was revolutionary about it
was about that ledger like if you have
your own checkbook you have a single
entry Ledger you're making your own
entries the medicis
500 years ago or so popular popularized
the idea of a double entry Ledger where
both the lender and the the borrower
both have a copy of the of The Ledger
that has two columns for both sides of
it and it prevented fraud from happening
and it's important note that that 600
years ago in the medici's popularized
Double Entry accounting that was our
dramatic change in business and allowing
businesses to grow because before that
there was this sort of general ledger
system that was more prone to fraud and
so businesses could really only grow to
the size of a circle of trust usually
inside of a family so that all of the
people that were participating just were
worthy of trust you knew who they were
but businesses were allowed to become
big businesses through the double entry
accounting change and that's really why
blockchain is so revolutionary and
people aren't totally getting yet how
giant it is because it makes it into a
triple entry Ledger that's right the bar
or the receiver and a copy that everyone
else has is that third entry the public
is the third entry so no changes can be
made in The Ledger and previous to this
triple entry accounting had been sort of
theorized but it hadn't been able to be
executed in a way that was trustworthy
and that's what blockchain brings us
okay
um
so I think from the point of view of the
audience it makes sense to
hear these explanations know that you're
not going to retain them you should
understand them as well as possible
first time through but
um you can sort of store them as the
punch line that's the way I would I
would go about it so uh let's take the
the medicis and double entry bookkeeping
our double Ledger bookkeeping
um into the evolutionary landscape we
would say
prior to this mechanism
the reason that business interactions
had to be retained at the family level
or something similar was because that A
reduced the incentive to cheat when you
treat your family member you also lose
and so the incentive to cheat is lower
but also it's iterated interactions your
family doesn't change chaotically so the
point is the incentive to maintain a
correct record so that those interaction
you know if you burn your credibility
with all the people with whom you can
trade then there's nobody to trade with
so it's a foolish thing to do so
everybody behaves more honorably yep
what you're describing
um is double entry bookkeeping allows
people who
um
don't necessarily have a permanent
relationship to trust the accounting
enough to proceed with a finite number
of transactions which basically allows
you to go from this very small scale to
an indefinitely large scale with a high
degree of safety not perfect you still
had to know who the other party was
because you still had to have some
degree of trackable trust with them if
they've made lies in the past you want
to keep track of who that was so that
you don't necessarily interact with them
in the future and the major change to
Triple accounting is you don't need to
know who the other party is
because everyone keeps The Ledger in
sync with each other and thus
trustworthy the security of The Ledger
is so high that nobody that who the
other person is is absolutely immaterial
if the math is right and the reporting
of the ongoing updating Ledger is
therefore accurate then
there's nothing to fear in the anonymity
of the other party you know exactly it's
not even a question of on the Bitcoin
blockchain there's never been a
fraudulent transaction no one has ever
double spent an amount of of coins no
one has ever been able to steal someone
else's on the blockchain itself there's
other aspects of this stack that can be
weaker right there are Shenanigans
they're at the weaker aspects of the
stack but within the blockchain itself
there's never been fraud which is yeah
there's enormous it's been running for
11 years yeah which is an amazing
technological feat I I will say one of
the maybe the fly in the ointment with
respect to blockchain uh generally
Bitcoin specifically is that
the
degree of understanding that is
necessary to effectively use it is high
and I could say maybe even more to the
point
there is an absolutely perilous stage of
utilizing it at which you know enough to
do it when it works but you are in
danger of putting money into this form
and losing access to it and there's
literally nobody on Earth who can help
you right so
um it feels like kind of we're at the IP
address phase of the web where the Nerds
can use it and they're super excited
about it and they can see the future of
what it can do and everything like that
but everyone else looks at and go you
want me to remember that 198. like no
that's absurd well we still aren't
necessarily it's not like just naming is
the solution it's a handful of little ux
Solutions in order to solve what you're
how to track your keys how to you know
protect them well how to make sure that
when you're sending a transaction it's
going to the intended party and not just
often to The Ether Etc agreed that's
part of it but it's also a question of
trade-offs as you would say right
because in our current Paradigm we have
no sovereignty we have no control right
like Google could cut off access to my
Gmail or my Google Docs at any time and
the trade-offs that you're making with
blockchain technology is that yes I do
have to take on some personal
responsibility to know what my keys are
but I also cannot be separated from my
data there is no third party there is no
intermediary who can come in and and do
something to cut off my access and so
it's that question of trade-offs and
those
user experience elements that Devin is
talking about are currently being
created where there are going to be
solutions to mitigate that incredible
risk that people feel of like okay well
I'm not used to basically being my own
Banker I'm used to having the bank
provide me this level of safety and then
I'm also used to even the the FDIC
Insurance providing me this level of
safety and I have none of that in this
other world and there are currently
tools being enabled for that as well
right and
um I would just as long as I mean I
really think it makes sense if if the
blockchain world is ever going to solve
its problem it needs to understand
you know this principle in software
design you are not the user right these
people who have become expert in
blockchain do not understand the uh the
high activation energy and
um the extraordinary you know you're
trading one kind of risk for another
um
great responsibility
well I mean hopefully with the great
currency comes great organizational
skills I agree because becoming you know
a risk to your own wealth because you
lose track of your access to it is uh
is a significant obstacle to people
adopting and because people to the
extent they have understood this have
generated tools that then place you at
some intermediate space in the trade-off
or subtly reverse it right so if you're
buying Bitcoin on an exchange right you
think you own Bitcoin but you don't you
own an IOU and that IOU means that
although it may be more robust there's a
reason for a crypto exchange not to want
to betray its user base in a way that
Google may not care but
um we've also seen some serious issues
with crypto exchanges as well obviously
right and so you're what you're talking
about right now is the difference
between custodial and non-custodial
holding of your funds and I'll just say
right up top here we definitely
recommend people to engage in
non-custodial forms of holding their
Bitcoin which basically means that
they're holding it themselves and there
are in fact Solutions not many people
are fully aware of them yet to what
you're speaking about of the
non-custodial part that you're fully
responsible and a lot of people don't
have very good password management
skills so if they don't have good pass
for management skills and they've spent
the last 10 20 years being trained by
the web that you don't have to you can
always click the password recovery
button they've trained themselves to not
be able to handle this responsibility
fortunately there are in fact solutions
for that if you have four or five
friends that you actually trust not so
much that you trust them individually to
have control of your money but you can
collectively trust them there are
technological solutions where you can
basically give them a part of something
that you can say hey I lost access to my
keys if three of five of you all agree
that I'm in fact me and I'm talking to
you personally you can recover my keys
for me
yep I I see it on the other hand I mean
let's just take one example of a problem
I used an exchange I used a major
Exchange in order to get into the crypto
market right
uh I had a slightly diverse portfolio I
had some Bitcoin and I had some uh
ethereum
at the point that issues of self-custody
became uh important as we watched
rickety-ness in the exchanges as we
watched
um Draconian measures following covid
where people were unable to access their
money for example in Canada the Canada
trucker thing The Exchange opens that
Hazard so what does one do well one
takes their crypto out of the exchange
and the problem is that if you convert
your currency from one currency to
another even though you're exchanging
one for one suddenly you get taxed right
because you've effectively uh converted
an ass set that varies in value you have
momentarily established its value and
the government takes an interest in that
money at a level of Taxation so you mean
when you moved it they considered it a
taxable event yep they didn't they they
may the The Exchange May in the
automatic reporting that they generate
for you they may make that assumption it
does it isn't actually true though you
moving it from you to you is still not
true so it wasn't it wasn't the you to
you it was the ethereum it was trading
from one to another yes yes yeah agreed
and that's frustrating I totally agree
but that's not a tech that's not a
technology issue it's a regular taxation
issue exactly and it's it's neither the
point is it is an obstacle to normal
getting into this type of currency as
good an idea as it may be the various
uncertainties and unknowns when am I
going to get hit by a tax I don't see
coming when am I going to discover that
although I think I own a whole bunch of
Bitcoin I don't because actually I
bought it through an exchange that gave
me an IOU and that's buried somewhere in
the fine print all of these things are
obstacles to people who know full well
that their dollars are not secure in the
way that they once were and might like
to at least diversify if not move out of
dollars entirely can't do it and it's
why these currencies can't be used as a
normal mode of exchange right the burden
of the technology is so high but of
course I'm not telling you anything you
don't know exactly to to to a certain
degree that's exactly why our
organization exists because that problem
is solved on two sides one educating
we've there's been no new regulations
written for the sake of crypto and some
people look at that and say why would
you want more regulations crypto is
about Freedom why would you want
because there's no new regulations
agencies like the SEC and the IRS are
assuming that it's something old
something that they've already figured
out how to regulate whether it be a
security a stock whatever else some of
them might be but because all those
things were were you know written into
law 100 years ago they certainly didn't
imagine the existence of this technology
and there's a handful of different ways
in which this technology actually solves
the problem that those regulations were
intending to solve for so double solving
that can actually create new problems so
we're we're looking forward to new
regulation and part of our job is to
help educate regulator or not regulate
well Regulators to some degree but
lawmakers themselves as best as possible
so they understand the technology and
they don't throw the baby out with the
bathwater one of the great examples that
we like to use is
um in the mid-1800s in England they were
leading the way on the development of
what would eventually become the
automobile you know turning the steam
engine into just putting it on four
wheels driving it through a town and
they were way ahead of the rest of the
world
um and lawmakers got scared of it I
assumed there was some accident and
people got hurt something like that the
lawmakers got scared of it and they
passed these things called the Red Flag
laws where everyone if you enter a city
you have to slow down to I think it was
two miles an hour you have to have
someone walk 40 yards out ahead waving
these red flags and warning everyone
that's coming and a lot of other
countries consider them too in the U.S
there was one that was considered where
if you were going to pass a horse and
carriage you need to literally park your
car behind a bushes and disassemble a
car so you don't scare the horses right
and so they actually implemented these
in in the UK and it destroyed the Nissan
industry that was trying to develop this
stuff and Germany saw the opportunity
and said
full steam ahead you know no pun
intended and they got the credit for
inventing the automobile and very
quickly after that England realized
their mistake and repealed all the laws
and they tried to catch up again this is
a global technology
the U.S some parts of the US are acting
like well we just own the tech industry
so whatever regulations we you know
Implement are going to be you know
worldwide and that's just not true other
countries see the see the value of this
so it's our job just to help American
lawmakers really understand the actual
value of this so that they can go about
fixing it but then or or building the
right set of rules for it but then the
other side is educating the public
because part of these problems are going
to be solved by the next wave of people
coming into it either the users that are
you know submitting complaints and
saying them in just the right way for
the for the engineers to go aha I
finally get it or the next wave of web 2
Engineers moving into web3 and saying I
have an idea for how to solve this I
think a lot of the solutions to these
things already exist in the market
they're just still being kind of hashed
out and then the next wave of of of of
growth for it is going to give the
opportunity for them to actually be
realized in a widespread way
well
um
I certainly hope that you're right
the vulnerability of fiat currency
is or the multiple vulnerabilities that
come from fiat currency are so great
that I can only hope that web 3 does
solve the many different obstacles and
hazards that accompany crypto
that said I'm stuck in the same place
that I am with let's say
um
Pharma and public health
used to say
I would certainly like to live in a
world where these things are well
regulated
I certainly don't trust the people in
the position of regulating them to do
more good than harm in fact again and
again and again we've seen the opposite
and so I'm sort of a uh I'm forced into
a Libertarian position that I do not
personally agree with because no
government is better than malignant
malignant government and I wonder if we
are not in the same place especially in
light of the obvious desire of the worst
elements of our governance structure to
force centralized Bank digital
currencies on us they obviously can't
have a thriving crypto sector because if
they do there will be a no reason to
embrace centralized Bank digital
currencies and you know in the worst
case scenario we might all end up
actually free and happy
you know what I mean I mean yeah yeah
what they want to prevent yeah well I
would say no go ahead okay
um the I would say the good news Focus
mostly on the financial applications of
this technology so far but there are
applications that are well beyond that
that are actually I think much more
exciting in terms of how they are going
to affect us on a day-to-day basis just
like average internet users like you and
me
and the the same principles apply here
in terms of transparency and
authenticity and that the entire way
that this technology can sort of re
remake the internet re decentralize its
structure is so profound that it can
bring back
the kind of trust that you're looking
for in these systems whether or not they
are regulated it's kind of like
the access to information that they will
provide the access to transparency of
that information of providence of that
information
Etc that they will provide will then
allow us all to look at that and say
well this this is how we think that
things should be done so regulation
could use that information in order to
better regulate whereas most of the
regulation right now is trying to say
there's some sort of
uh what's that word a
um a Sync It's not synchronous
asymmetrical
information right that's why stocks have
to you know have these public
disclosures right and that's just sort
of not necessary when it comes to
blockchain technology because the by
their nature they're public and by their
nature they they're transparent and have
this record of you know when things
happened and who was involved with them
if it's more indelible than anything
else on the web all right I want to
pause you there because I think uh there
is a trichotomy here that people need to
be uh they're sort of dimly aware of it
but they need to be pretty well versed
in it to understand what you might be
talking about okay so you tell me if
I've got this wrong
but what you have is
um
you have blockchain technology
and what you are now talking about is
the use of blockchain blockchain
technology for something other than
cryptocurrency
right and so
uh blockchain is this Ledger mechanism
you are describing uh
the Bitcoin uh Ledger what it tracks is
just debits and credits that's it other
ones track other stuff other types of
data ah so if people people need to
separate these things in their mind
because the first use case for the first
major use case for this technology is
cryptocurrency people have them
synonymized in their mind and it's
really important for much of what you
guys are talking about that they'd be
able to separate these things and
understand that that ledger technology
can be used for all sorts of things as
you're pointing out and it's news to me
but as you're pointing out the original
use of blockchain was apparently a
authenticity uh record it was not about
currency at all exactly so the currency
uh at the point of the
um the Bitcoin white paper become
this use case that then has the
potential
to replace Fiat currencies and so it
captured the public imagination but it
has unfortunately synonymized the two
things so for the point of view from the
perspective of trying to maintain an
understanding of these things blockchain
is separate from crypto and Bitcoin is
the largest
um blockchain utilizing cryptocurrency
there is and it was the original one
it's far from the only one
um but anyway keeping those things
Bitcoin is not crypto and crypto is not
blockchain that is an important
distinction to maintain yeah so the
in blockchain what it did was it
combined some previously existing
Technologies to create Bitcoin it can
bind blockchain with public key
cryptography and it used proof of work
for its consensus those three pieces had
all been done previously Haven's
dornetta had done blockchain Adam back
had done proof of work and I mean public
key cryptography is just like it's how
TLS works yeah it's just like yeah
anything is encrypted on the web and so
um
so combining those was like the big
innovation that Bitcoin brought forward
and because the proof of work mechanism
is incentivized because a sum of
blockchains is released every time a new
block is created some of the Bitcoin
what did I say there's some with
blockchains
um then that's what incentivized the use
of the network and so when you say like
they're different they are different in
terms of their application but a lot of
them still have that incentive mechanism
and that incentive mechanism is really
really important I would say it is what
allows web3 to be a realistic Vision
whereas before it wasn't because we've
had certain decentralized Technologies
for more than 20 years you know we've
had BitTorrent forever and it's just
holding it home and study at home for
example
okay like they they've been around for I
think five years ten years longer than
Bitcoin and Bitcoin is dramatically more
powerful of a network and it's because
of the financial incentive because all
of the workers that are participating
with study at home and folding at home
it was just hey use your idle computer
time to do these important things you
know cure cancer and find whether
there's aliens in the universe these are
really important things but it was all
voluntary
and so you weren't going to get
commercial activity you weren't going to
get people dedicating real resources to
it because of
proof of work was the solution to the
centralized to the central point of
failure that sternetta and and um Haber
had uh and part of that was because it
gave the the workers that were creating
each new block an incentive to do that
they were getting paid and almost every
blockchain I can think of has that in
common so there is a financial aspect to
every single one of them but the
financial aspect just incentivizes the
continuing The Continuous operation of
the rest of the Network's operations it
incentivizes or orchestrates the network
to work properly we've had BitTorrent
for all of these years but it's just
become known as a piracy thing because
the people who are involved in
maintaining that Network do it just
because they care about it you can't
count on a file to be on the BitTorrent
Network for you I mean now they have
created a token so you know I'm talking
about before that but
um you can't count on that file to be
there for you even though the Dynamics
of a network like BitTorrent compared to
the cdns that we use now are wildly more
efficient they produce wildly better
results they're wildly less expensive to
to operate and yet the the structure of
the cdns that we have right now the
centralized ones where we have kind of
this like funneling problem where the
more popular something gets the lower
quality it is the slower it gets to you
you know the more expensive it is for
the platform that's providing it to you
um that's
that doesn't work when you compare it to
a decentralized network and all of what
it can provide to you but you couldn't
count on those decentralized networks
until we had that incentive piece so
it's just you can't dismiss it yeah
let's uh let's translate this into
English and then biology
um so study at home is a great example
right study at home you could use your
spare computer time to look for patterns
in the universe that might indicate
aliens cool but why would you well maybe
you'll find aliens and people will
interview you about what it was like to
be the first person to spot an alien
pattern but the chances are pretty damn
low and so it was pretty limited you had
to be kind of enthusiastic about it and
maybe a little altruistic and neither of
those things uh are a payout in and of
themselves they're not sustainable right
they're not sustainable and in fact the
altruism piece
um is a is a penalty really then you
have something like BitTorrent why did
torrent work better than study at home
well because you did have an incentive
to log into the network right you had an
incentive to log into the network which
is that you wanted to download something
get some free music right and as long as
you are logged in for your own selfish
purposes then maybe you feel a little
Shame about not doing your part maybe uh
your you notice that the it's really
free to you to allow the extra bandwidth
that you've paid for to be used in this
way and so maybe you're sticking it to
the man whatever it is there's some
reason once you're logged in for your
own purposes for you to do a little bit
of the heavy lifting that doesn't cost
you anything but it's still not a payoff
right it's still it's like a kind of
it's like holding a door for somebody
it's a kind of altruism that is so cheap
that why wouldn't you you're not going
to dedicate enough Computer Resources
that will increase your electricity bill
or you're not gonna you know buy a bunch
of extra Hardware to do it because
that's an outlay of cost that you're not
going to get back from the network right
but you might throw a little you know
it's like throwing uh cardboard in the
recycling bin rather than the trash
right exactly exactly a tiny bit of
effort you might as well and then
there's a question about well what if
you were actually you know what if you
were paid and you know we've seen silly
examples of this or somewhat silly
examples of this like uh bounties on
glass and aluminum that do cause people
who are really in Desperate Straits to
try to accumulate enough aluminum to
actually go buy a sandwich or whatever
um but if you actually got paid serious
money then you'd do it because why
wouldn't you and in fact we've seen that
this is so successful that it is now
actually uh driven the price of computer
hardware that's good at this sort of
thing through the roof and created
scarcity right because the amount you
can get
paid by doing the work that is the
central part of proof of work
is substantial in fact you can make a
lot of money
all that correct yes okay so what you
are saying is
um incentives matter this of course
shouldn't be news to anyone of course
incentives matters why we do everything
and it's why we're actually built the
way we are right right why does sex feel
good uh it has something to do with the
fact that your ancestors passed their
genes on through this behavior and
therefore a system was built to create
an internal reward so that you would be
driven to this thing right so if that
kind of logic is of course how you would
build a system that actually worked
unlike something like like seti right so
all right given that you have barriers
to entry for the web 3 space you have
incentives to participate at a high
level and you have trade-offs for us who
those of us who are not likely to end up
doing the the work of the network but
maybe would like the security of a
currency that uh is immune to fraud
um or immune to governmental
interference right barriers to entry
that keep us from utilizing it
um so
uh okay all of that is true for the
currency side and then there's the
question about if we take the currency
out of this
and we look at the Technologies you're
talking about a mechanism for ensuring
authenticity well suddenly authenticity
is on a lot of people's minds because we
recognize that we're like hours away
from Deep fakes that are so good that
you can't detect somebody looking at you
know the direction of the shadows and
the stuff that we used to be able to do
to figure out whether a photograph was
for real so yeah so Devin used to be a
compositor before we got into this
industry he was working in the
entertainment industry and so I like to
say like he's the reason that photos no
longer hold up in court right because he
could create images that were
photorealistic you would totally believe
and we would look at things like which
direction or the shadow is coming from
that kind of stuff was really important
and getting it right means you can go to
a movie and actually have the suspension
of disbelief and that same exact person
or technology can do it to make you know
fakes on the web so it's always it's
been around for 20 or 30 years the thing
is that it took faster way it took an
enormous team of compositors to make
make images that that didn't really
exist to look believable right you you
had to have a tremendous amount of
resources and now you don't have to
anymore or you won't have to very soon
you know the AI is not quite there yet
the sixth finger and stuff is usually a
pretty good giveaway right but if they
just solve for the hands recently
getting better and better and when we
first saw this
um I think it was in like 20
20 2019 Devin was like wow I cannot
believe it this is so exciting the kind
of filmmaking that's going to come out
of this is just he was just like giddy I
was horrified because I had because I'm
a woman and I had just an innate
understanding of the way that this
technology could be used to hurt me
where you know you've seen celebrities
kind of have these deep faked images of
them naked doing disgusting things
whatever I know
um
Anita
from college you know and so I just was
like oh this is going to put this down
onto a level where it's going to apply
to Everyday People it's not just going
to apply to celebrities that that
something like this could happen to you
and then all of a sudden people are
going to be looking at you sideways as
if those images you know you had
participated in the creation of those
images you know it's just I don't know
it gets me kind of flustered still so we
actually made a video about this to
illustrate this problem and I got a
friend of mine to shoot some kind of
like sexy bikini footage and Devin
calmed my face onto her body just to
show like to give people a visual image
of like this is a threat to all of us
and
it's a threat that's like very real at
this point now with where we are in the
progression of things and so that takes
us to
the cryptography element that the
authenticity element and before you get
there I want to say first of all you
guys showed me that video years ago I
guess this would have been pre-coveted
am I right yeah right before covered
yeah I think it was right before coven
um I'm still slightly disturbed by it
I am too I had to make it right well
there yeah even worse for you
um but yeah and I think the point is you
know my conscious mind understands that
this was done to prove a point right but
some part of me like has this disturbing
image of my friend Amy and it's like you
know that Hazard is going to become
ubiquitous because the tool that is
going to allow you to generate this is
going to be so low effort that people
are going to create uh every video that
serves to hurt somebody they don't like
or that they get off on or whatever
they're gonna do and the point is that's
a frightening world to live in right and
to impact geopolitical events you know
the the Pentagon bombing a couple of
weeks ago that caused a half a trillion
dollars of market cap to be briefly lost
like that's dramatic I mean in that case
it's absurd that anyone reacted that way
because it wasn't even in the shape of a
pentagon it had all those artifacting
things that people talk about so with a
few seconds of looking at it you could
tell that this is fake but it spooked
the heck out of the market and I think
mostly it's booked the market because
they were like
okay we figured it out pretty quickly
but pretty soon we're not going to be
able to and mainly they were just scared
by the implications of this I think it
was a risk aversion they don't know what
this means even if you know it isn't
what it is you're never gonna be able to
trust anything we see again exactly
exactly and when these fakes get really
really good I mean basically we're going
to be in an arms race where the
detectors are going to be pitted against
the generators and we're going to get to
a level where no human is able to detect
anything fortunately there's a much
better way to actually distinguish
except for hold on hold on before we get
there I wanna I wanna complete this
dystopian picture of the world that's
coming if we don't do something and I
think it can be summed up in the
following phrase picks and it didn't
happen
yeah you said something else um
everything is a psyop assume everything
until proven otherwise until proven
otherwise exactly even otherwise and
actually uh oh go ahead well no but
Pixar didn't happen like how do you even
attention to pix and it didn't happen
right you have vivid picks that prove it
happened and yet it didn't it didn't
happen it didn't happen yeah right
um but that you know but okay so then if
you teleport yourself into that world
before you guys ride to the rescue with
a technology that might save us from it
problem is okay you can adapt to that
world how
total cynicism right Psy up until proven
otherwise and the point is do you really
want to live in a world
in which uh you're you in which your
eyes are incapable of telling you what
happened unless it happened immediately
in front of you right no it's not
because the internet it is the greatest
Library that's ever existed and I don't
we we just had a son and I don't want my
son to grow up without the resource of
the greatest Library that's ever existed
right and in which basically it is a uh
a cesspool of Nefarious claims backed up
with evidence that even if your
conscious mind can dismiss it your
subconscious mind will make whatever of
it that it will make and exactly you
know it's it's it's
um
and it's like you said it's like once
you see it you you have forever seen it
you can't unsee it and so wouldn't it be
great if you could just make sure that
those things never ended up in your feed
to begin with but you could also know
that those filters weren't being used
nefariously to suppress information you
wanted access to wouldn't that be
amazing hey hey is there a technological
solution to this that might delete us
there perhaps yeah so what's so funny
about this is that to everyone inside
the crypto industry this answer is like
plain as day super obvious I feel almost
silly talking about it but to everyone
on the outside of the industry it's like
what are we gonna do we need detectors
because we're not going to be able to
tell the difference between these kinds
of images you know we're gonna and and
are the detectors even gonna be able to
keep up blah blah blah blah
the very simple answer to this problem
is public key cryptography uh Fred
Wilson wrote an article called sign
everything that's extremely well written
and just like very straightforward if
people want to read that I recommend it
but but basically what it means is that
um so public private key cryptography
uses key pairs so the the keys have a
mathematical relationship well hold on
let's before we get to that the before
public key cryptography we only had
what's called uh symmetric cryptography
and this is what's been used since you
know kind of Roman times kind of thing
where the key that is used to encrypt
something is also the key that is used
to decrypt something so you need to have
a distribution mechanism for those keys
so that whoever is on the other side is
able to receive it and no one intercepts
it in the middle yeah if you and I sit
down at a table and we take the alphabet
and we agree that an a for the P Etc
when I go our separate ways I can send
you a letter and you take your copy of
the key and you decrypt it Dakota Rings
exactly yeah um and this was used this
was even used through World War II and
one of the the major if you ever saw the
movie um the imitation game what it was
basically talking about is they were
trying to figure out a general computer
that its purpose is to be able to
decrypt the the the axis uh messages
because they were using cryptography and
they figured it out they were able to
decrypt them and they didn't want to let
the Germans know so they couldn't like
you know give all these tails and stuff
like that but it able it enabled them to
make strategic decisions to shorten the
length of the war and to win the war
sooner and it was because they broke
their cryptography because they were
dependent on symmetric cryptography so
one of the reasons that the web became
like one of the things that made web one
go into web 2 was the introduction of
TLS and SSL like why you have that
little lock on your on your uh URL when
you used to be when you'd visit your
bank now it's on every web page is it it
uses a combination of symmetric and
asymmetric cryptography the difference
there is that like Amy was describing it
involves a key pair and we probably
shouldn't go into all the details of
this Amy actually made a video about it
that's one of you know obviously we make
a lot of videos to teach this stuff so
if anyone wants to really really get
into this stuff they should watch that
particular video
um but it depends on a key pair where
you have one that is private and that
you maintain and one that is public and
they are they are mathematically related
to each other and so anyone can using
just math nothing else be able to prove
that if I put something out in the world
that is derived from my from my private
key and uh and and I've also shared my
public key they can know with certainty
that that thing was in fact derived from
my private key there is a one-to-one
relationship that can't be faked by
anyone else Etc and you can't reverse
engineer the public key back to the
private key people will have some
experience with this right there was
somebody in everybody's Circle who used
pgp pgp a large sequence of asking
exactly extended ASCII characters at the
end of it and it would say pgp block
begin pgp block end and if you weren't
encrypting you ignored it but if you
wanted to send this person a message
that was truly private you could use
that thing there was no that's the
Republican to anybody it was useless on
its own you could use it to encrypt the
message that they had the decoder ring
for on the other side and those two
things were generated in tandem at the
beginning right the computer you would
give it some random inputs move your
mouse or something like that to give it
some numbers that were not predictable
from anything and it would generate this
pair of keys and then your private
version you had to guard and it was also
guarded by a password that presumably
you it could be really hard not to write
down anywhere yeah right
um and so anyway that password allowed
you to access your private key which
didn't mean anything to you either it
was only useful if you got a message
that had been in encrypted with your
public one and voila a message could
arrive it didn't matter if it was
intercepted because nobody could read it
and when you got it you could open it up
and decrypt it with your half of this
this thing and right not impossible to
break it but at levels of foreseeable
levels of computing power
the mathematical the Computing
horsepower necessary to break it put it
what was it tens of thousands of years
in the future if you set a computer to
the task of guessing and it just kept
yeah yeah exactly but like you said it
never caught on right there was like one
person in your circle that used it
because it was this kind of like onerous
thing to do to encrypt your email it
wasn't that hard but it was just this
extra step it was super annoying but
then protonmail built it in to its
software and so now you and I can
exchange emails just as we would on any
other email software only it's fully
encrypted end to end automatically
without automatically doing anything
extra
yeah and that can be applied to this as
well
right now again I I mean I really think
I hope that the crypto folks will turn
the lasers off in their eyes for a
little bit and just tune into this
podcast and hear hear about the problem
of all of these Technologies
um but the reason that pgp never caught
on was not just that it was a little
weird right once you went through the
process of generating the keys it was
easy enough but the point is okay so I
have let's say I have your key Devin and
I send you a message very likely the
next thing that happens is you're going
to send me another key and say could you
encrypt that again I no longer have the
private key to decrypt that message you
just sent me right that happens all the
time because just management with
cryptocurrency you can lose access to
stuff that you're entitled to have and
um you know so protonmail I use it
myself
it's a great example of what can be done
on the other hand it now introduces the
problem of like the crypto exchange
right you are now dependent on
protonmail being what it appears to be
right and that's an additional problem
so right and you're and you're dependent
on Pro because proton male is
maintaining the servers where your
information is you know is stored
essentially right and most people don't
download a copy of their own private key
it's just stored exactly right and so
while we all just take the leap of faith
and trust that protonmail is encrypting
everything end to end and they don't
have any sort of back doors into that
and it is on their servers and so if
somebody were to subpoena the
information on the servers they wouldn't
necessarily be able to access our
information that's all a leap of faith
that we're making
and what we're talking about with web3
is
um decentralizing you know the full
protocol stack so that so that it's
decentralized all the way down to the
layer of the server infrastructure
itself right there's a protocol called a
cache that you can use to rent server
infrastructure so that you're not
necessarily using a single provider and
it's it's literally just decentralizing
the server infrastructure itself so
we're in this weird time right now where
most of us are still on web 2 web 3 is
sort of being built and the bridges from
web 2 to web 3 aren't obvious and are
being experimented on to see what what
makes it easy what people like what
makes it and even really what's
necessary so a lot of people are calling
this like web 2.5 because there are uh
some apps that are out there right now
where a piece of their app is
decentralized right they're built on
our weave or they're built on ipfs so
they have this aspect of
decentralization because they they're
you know decentralized file storage but
they're also you know have a client
that's hosted on a server so that you
can just go to www.whatever and get to
it directly and that piece is still
centralized because they're running it
on Amazon web services because they
haven't felt the pressure to
decentralize all the way down to that
server layer and have it hosted instead
by a cache for example because you know
building your your a new protocol stack
where the app is decentralized you know
all the way down is a lot more work than
what you're currently used to doing just
because these Protocols are still being
built essentially right yep so we just
add one more thing before we move fully
away from the the sign everything the
extra layer to that we were only talking
about how to encrypt things so that they
stay private you know I'm sending it to
you and only you can decrypt it the
other thing that you can do with this is
I could take some message that I'm going
to put out into the world publicly and I
can create a signature based on that
message using my private key to decrypt
it and because my public key is
available to anyone anyone can use the
public key to decrypt that signature and
what that tells them is the signature
was generated based on the thing that
I'm sharing and it was generated by my
private key and only my private key so
it's a way that I could put up a blog
post or a video or anything else I want
and attach a signature to it and that
signature is mathematical proof that the
thing hasn't been altered since I signed
it that thing that I'm sharing the blog
post or the video and that I'm the one
that actually shared it and so that's
that's the extra layer that we use in
order to figure out that authenticity
aspect of the stuff being shared on the
on the internet that especially if as
this fear is growing and especially as
actual Market impact is growing there
will become more of an awareness that
this is the the way to solve this and
thus we will adopt this this new
perspective of sign everything if you
want it to be perceived as authentic
from your followers from the public from
the government anyone else that you want
something to be perceived as
authentically from you you attach a
signature to it it's incredibly simple
for you to do so and anyone in the world
can mathematically prove that it came
from you it didn't come from anyone else
and it hasn't been altered well I'm
really glad that you brought that up and
the thing about that is that he's making
it sound like it would be this manual
process that you would have to engage in
and what really what it is is that you
could use an app that's integrated that
and so that's what I was talking about
where wouldn't it be great if your feed
could automatically be filtered so that
you're not seeing any of the stuff any
of the garbage but you but you can also
audit those filters to know that they
are not you know being used to suppress
information okay I need I need help
understanding some aspects of this okay
something
shows up in my feed it appears to be
a video of some event that would matter
if it happened but would be trivial to
with the help of AI generate something
that made it look like it happened and
it didn't
what does this system do for me
I can look suppose there's no signature
right don't trust it I I can filter it
out on the basis that if it were genuine
it would have one exactly has a
signature
that's unknown to me that exactly that's
only been used to sign one thing before
so again what you know is this doesn't
have the the party they released this
doesn't have any track record of trust
in the past so you can treat it as you
want like some people might say well at
least they signed it they're they're
starting to establish a track record but
I know that it's less trustworthy than
the Thousand messages that I know were
published by Amy and all used the same
key that the same public key so I know
all those came from her and she has a
whole history of them whereas this one
that's a really huge event it's signed
but by a key that's only been used once
so the person that signed it had no
interest in establishing their past
track record of trust so we can go back
to your picks and it didn't happen
assume nothing is true assume everything
is a psyop unless it's proven otherwise
the signature proves otherwise it proves
something it gives you some piece of
information so right you're getting to
the issue of trust and and just because
something is signed and just because
something is on a blockchain doesn't
mean that it's trustworthy and I think
that that gets conflated so I'm really
glad that you're bringing that up no
what it does is yeah I get that it's not
you could put garbage on a blockchain
and not only is there garbage on the
blockchain but it'll be there forever
but yeah
um but it does allow me if it's if
something's never been signed I could
set a filter that says I only want to
see things from sources that have
signed a hundred things or more that I
can then go look at and see whether or
not you know I could have signed trivial
things you know 100 you can see them
right right and then I know oh that's
not that doesn't strike me as likely to
be worth trust proof right or it could
be somebody who has you know documented
some
thing that I can otherwise verify you
know I I don't know what the pattern
might be that would suggest that this
was a source putting a signature onto
your social media profile
then as long as you trust that the
tweets that are coming out of someone if
you've interacted with them on Twitter
and you trust that it's them and they
have created a loop between their public
key and their and their Twitter profile
or their Instagram profile whatever that
attaches them to them like the person
that has those keys also has the login
information for that Twitter account
yeah this gets a sum fraction of the
distance
um it's that bridge right between web 2
and web three it's like okay well what
we have right now are these profiles on
social media and we assume that they are
you know who they say that they are for
the most part it used to be that that
blue check told us that somehow the
platform was involved in verifying and
saying who that they until they were
dealing with a very high quality person
that's no longer that's no longer a
filter because you can just buy that now
so you know it's it's it is tricky we're
in a tricky landscape here right are you
going to put up you know your your ID
along with your public key like wow that
would be a lot to put out there
um but you're right that that that we
need these sort of steps along the way
to say to give it that verification
there's other uh things that have been
played with where it was kind of like
what Devin was saying when you can share
your keys with friends and that they can
help you to recover them you can also do
that with attestation of like this
person is who they say that they are
that was being done with land records at
one point was something we were working
on it was like key signing parties where
people get together and they show their
ID to the other people that are having
pizza with them and whatnot and then
they sign something and so now if you
have if I have trust for all the
statements you're making online and you
attest that these 10 other people that
you met at this at this particular event
are who they say they are then that
increases my love of trust of them as
well
okay
um
I see
what's getting obscured in this is that
this is a giant
uh leap from
the zero trust future that is coming
almost immediately if we don't have this
right right a world where everybody will
either be a uh a permanent rube
right it's being suckered left and right
or a cynic who can't be convinced of
anything right that's the two Futures we
have if we don't have a technology
neither of those are good for us exactly
both of them are disastrous failure mods
and a mixture is a even worse one
um yeah
but
this provides a mechanism to solve the
cynicism problem right it gives you a
basis on which you can establish Trust
of a certain amount of stuff yep the
world will still be full of
untrustworthy stuff and you won't
necessarily know what to think of it
right if I see that a particular image
that suggests a particular fact belongs
to a Twitter profile that has
five thousand followers and follows
300 people and has posted on a variety
of topics and is followed by three
people I know right that is not a
garbage account
but it's not a highly trustworthy
account from my perspective it's just
somebody who probably exists right
um
so anyway the point is that's an
intermediate level of trust this doesn't
give me a high degree of confidence of
that image and it also I hesitate to say
opens a
frightening landscape of possibilities
with respect to what the value of a
highly trusted Source signing a false
piece of information would be
and then what happens in a world where
somebody has spent a lifetime building
up credibility and then somebody puts a
gun to their head to borrow it to
establish a fact that is in the fact
right that's a frightening Prospect yeah
but
you know I mean again I hate to
introduce that here because I do think
there's a frightening landscape of
uh potential abuses here that we will
only learn about after such a thing
exists but I do think such a thing has
to exist because the cynicism failure
mode is you know it's next week right
it's catastrophic yeah yeah so I
wouldn't necessarily say that agree
though that that is a newly introduced
issue because without that all we all we
have to trust people is as far as people
we see on the internet is the fact that
they have the ability to log into an
account and if they've built up a large
following and they've built up a lot of
credibility someone coming to a gun with
their head the exact same thing they're
not asking for their for them to sign
something with their private Keys
they're asking for their Twitter
credentials same exact threat
yeah you're you're you're right about
this and I do wonder how much of our uh
our world view is shaped by
people who have established credibility
and have some vulnerability or being
you know manipulated agreed let's say I
don't when I look at Bill Gates and I
see what he's doing
um with respect to Public Health
it looks diabolical to me but what I
don't know is whether his connection to
Epstein caused him effectively to be a
robot doing somebody else's bidding that
isn't really what he would be dedicating
his time to if he was a free person I
don't know
um so for that reason a healthy degree
of cynicism about what other people say
is going to be important no matter what
version of this we're in well I don't
know how someone's being manipulated
there's healthy skepticism skepticism
thank you much better right
I mean this is unfortunate because the
healthy people are going to going to go
to cynicism if if let's hope not but
yeah provide a tool and it's and this is
the only thing I've heard that uh at
least provides the first uh stepping
stone to a world in which we can again
establish some basis for trusting stuff
right yeah I mean what you're talking
about does sound like just a very dark
sad world if that is where we proceed
and I think that you know I'm not
naturally a person drawn to technology
by any stretch I in fact find a lot of
the things that we work on quite boring
but
this technology is the hope it is the
way out in my opinion and once you
understand it enough to understand what
it can provide
it's
it's like okay yeah let's start running
toward the light because there is there
is an option here and
um
and so it becomes really exciting that
we could build this sort of
decentralized Library of Alexandria
that's what our project was actually
first called when we first got started
you know that's immune from the kind of
Destruction that the first one suffered
because it has this decentralized aspect
so as long as a single copy exists it
still exists and so that it has all of
these tools to make that information
more
hmm
I don't know something that you have
more resources to evaluate
and and analyze well and just to add the
controversial element one of those tools
is going to be personal AI
because pattern ai's good at recognizing
patterns and if you've got that person
who has a history of posting somewhat
trustworthy things that they've grown up
a following and then suddenly they start
talking about other things and those
other things are also being shared by
other accounts that aren't very
trustworthy you might not be able to
detect that as easy as your personal AI
assistant
well actually this is I don't know if
you want to jump to AI but this might be
the moment to do that in this
conversation because Ai and web3 they
really need each other you know web3
solves a lot of the problems that AI
that are concerns about Ai and
AI won't be able to get to the market
without web 3 and so that's going to
bring web3 along you know there have
been a lot of us that are like what is
going on why has web3 taken so long to
catch on like why is it still so complex
why is it still so difficult to access
why isn't it more integrated into
everyday apps for end users not for
Developers
you know it took it took the web less
time to catch on web one than it has for
web 3 to catch on what is going on and
um the AI issue is really I think going
to be a breakout moment for web 3
because
you can't get access to some of the
things that you need to build Ai and
web3 can provide that like access to the
gpus
fill that in for me a little bit I'm
trying to understand
um you know my sense is the web 3
taking so long
is a matter of all of the various
complexities
that you solve at the expense of robbing
it of its value
right
um
you know sort of yes and no like the the
crypto exchanges you want some crypto
you know as an investment oh you can get
it on an exchange very easily just use
your credit card but what did you give
up you know you are now exposed to the
risk that the government is going to
decide that you're a bad person who's
not entitled to spend their money or
that the exchange is going to go
bankrupt and you're low on the list of
creditors or whatever it is that might
happen and so
you know the
the
difficulty in separating the
technological obstacles and the
knowledge necessary to properly interact
with it is robbing uh producers of the
incentive to generate the
mode of interaction because the audience
is limited okay yeah that makes sense
and I think that because it's been so
focused on the financial applications up
until now it adds this like degree of
danger that's been sort of off-putting
and I think that's what I mean about web
3 and AI having this breakout moment
together because AI is going to be using
the that web3 infrastructure that we've
talked about so when I talk about web3
infrastructure I'm referring to what I
like to call the plumbing of the web
it's the kinds of things that the
protocols that are responsible for the
things that we do on the web day in and
day out that we never even think about
so the kinds of things that are allowing
us to be on this video call right now
you know decentralized file storage
video transcoding content indexing
um all the things that a computer can do
that you need to kind of put into
various data centers in order for the
web to exist have I think all of them at
this point have now a decentralized
analog that can do that thing with a
higher degree of trust where you're not
having to depend entirely on say AWS or
YouTube to do it for you you're using a
decentralized network that is
transparent you can see it and it's
actually running on some individual's
computer somewhere yeah I want to ask
you about that though yeah
my impression and you know you the three
of us have talked about this many times
over the last however many years and my
sense is that all of this stuff is now
doable in some decentralized form and
much of it is quite good but there's
nothing that doesn't yet have that lacks
a central point of failure and so my
sense is no matter how much you
decentralize there's a point at which
you're going to run up against one of
the protocols at the bottom of this
stack right and somebody has ultimate
control over it whether that's if your
DNS exactly that's a totally reasonable
worry because if you leave one central
point of failure in there then that's
the point of Leverage and so you don't
want to
um and you're actually incorrect about
that the whole stack has now been
decentralized including uh ISP access
and DNS access so you can do storage you
can do video processing you can do
compute you can do everything you need
to on the web in a fully decentralized
way including there there are in fact
decentralized wireless networks or
decentralized
um you know cell phone networks where
someone literally puts a little kind of
small personal uh cell tower on their
house on their you know on their roof or
whatever and it creates uh uh access for
everyone in their area and they earn
cryptocurrency in exchange for doing
that for Crea for uh enabling their
Broadband to have access to it uh and
them keeping the hardware up and and
running and it actually what's really
smart about the way this the one I'm
thinking of in particular is called
helium is if it doesn't do you any good
in like a major city to have 10 of them
that are directly overlapping and not
actually increasing the amount of
bandwidth available so it's biased
toward filling in the holes in the
network so wherever there's physical
gaps you get paid a higher amount if you
fill that Gap
cool all right so I would say that where
we are though in terms of the
development of these things is that the
individual protocols for these things
exist and now we need developers to come
along and and bundle them up build that
app for end users that allows you and me
easy access to engage in these systems
with these protocols in a fully
decentralized way because right now you
just have kind of like
apps built on one of the protocols and
so it's kind of this like mishmash where
it's not like a real thing that you and
I can actually fully interact with yet
but we're super close to that and we're
getting there more and more every day so
are we uh you know I don't want to force
it to this metaphor if it's really not
right but there was an ERA a computer
era
um you know I I had an apple too when I
was a kid and it was a command line
interaction
it was
doable right you need to know a little
bit to operate it and the more you knew
the more you could do with it but it was
you know the command line was an
obstacle right because most people did
not know what to do with the flashing
cursor and the fact that you couldn't
talk to it in English was a deal killer
and then Apple
borrowing from other people including
Xerox
realized that
running it required familiar metaphors
right and that a trash can
a virtual trash can that you could drag
stuff you no longer wanted to was good
and that a folder
was equally good and that copy and paste
and cut right that these metaphors were
going to be the thing that allowed
normal people to interact with the
computer and then at some point you
realize
there's no reason that that file has to
live in a folder it could live in all
relevant folders simultaneously that
it's not limited to the physics of a
folder and so you get this mixture of
the constraints that come with metaphors
and then people who get used to those
metaphors can then be induced to break
the mental constraints and to free
themselves from some understanding but
but really the point is what made
computers viable for most people
was metaphors and but what are the
metaphors doing they're actually
obscuring the complexity behind things
that aren't complex
so again I know you're not necessarily a
fan of this but that's what AI is going
to do and is already doing we we we're
just looking at two articles about
um web 3 platforms that are introducing
AI one of them that is just a chat bot
sitting on top of their documentation so
that any web 2 developer who wants to
implement this stuff can just chat with
a chatbot get all the answers they need
and then another one is a whole web3
search engine so that anyone can come
along and ask any question of the about
the entirety of all the webs because
there's thousands of protocols at this
point it's hard to track them all it's
hard to especially because they're
constantly all evolving and so that's
one of the ways that it that the
complexity can be obscured behind asking
simple questions and getting direct
simple answers oh look I'm all for that
and in fact
uh every computer language is such a
thing right it's an intermediate level
of complexity and the fact is
essentially nobody speaks machine
language and so
um you know that's always been the
mechanism to get these things to work
and frankly even
in technological
Realms where we think we're talking
about the real substance of the matter a
whole lot of what we say even inside of
the hard Sciences is metaphor
you know for the parts that one does not
have to be specific about so you can get
to the particular question about what
you're trying to be very very concrete
so this is how the human mind functions
and in some sense my uh my message in
this podcast is
you gotta maybe they're just you need a
Steve Jobs right you need a Steve Jobs
who spent his time in what was it uh
calligraphy class that caused him to
realize that fonts mattered right you
need you need the font people and you
need the metaphor people and you know in
some sense you guys are the bridge
because I know you guys think in both
ways but until web 3 has that component
where one sits down with it and you have
the pleasure of exploring of discovering
what is possible rather than the uh gee
I guess I need to spend another couple
hours with the manual right because yeah
I wouldn't want to operate this saw
without doing that you know it's got to
work more like
um
like a computer game that you can sit
down with and start
feeling empowered right away rather than
a dangerous tool that you better not you
know Skip a paragraph where it's going
to hurt you 100 yep exactly and I would
say like my message in this podcast
would be web 2 developers your time is
now like make the leap to web3 because
the tools are there for you now to be
able to quickly build apps for end users
and those apps can be 10x more powerful
than what you're building on web2 by
doing so it's going to make your app
more successful and let's be honest web
2 is where all of the people that have
or a great number of the people that
have the skills you're talking about are
still employed and they've yet to make
that leap because there's this
perception that it's all financial
services and there's some amount of
overlap between the interest of tech and
finance but it's not incredibly high and
so most of the first wave of this is
finance related Finance focused people
just a few years ago you did need to
have sort of special skills you needed
to be blockchain developer to be able to
participate and that's just no longer
the case now you just need to be a web
developer to build something on top of
it and it can still run completely
decentralized because web is just web is
just code it can be running locally in
your own environment it can be running a
decentralized network or it could be
running on AWS and all we really need is
we need the alternative to AWS to be
less expensive and more trustworthy and
that already exists so now there's good
enough reason for web developer for you
to run your web server on something like
a cache but where Amy was going earlier
is
not only is that true for AI but it in
fact even solves a constraint issue that
AI doesn't have us that the web 2 era
doesn't really have a solution for
there's a handful of new gpus that are
coming out
um called the a100 and the h100 that are
so powerful they're twenty thousand
dollars a piece
they're incredibly constrained Supply
and so like one thing we've heard is
that a lot of VCS are trying to buy them
as fast as possible because then they
can like add them as a little uh uh
[Music]
if they try to offer someone a deal if
they want to invest in some AI startup
and they're competing with someone else
they can say well I've got access to the
a100 you get access to that kind of
thing
um so a cache we were talking about
earlier is like the decentralized AWS
it's a general compute where anyone can
offer some Hardware up to the network
and anyone else on the other side it's
basically just a Marketplace for compute
right
so you're talking about you know you
have a computer sitting on your desk and
most of the time it's doing very little
exactly and you can you could pool those
resources right right I could I can rent
also a lot of unused space and data
centers like more than you would guess
and that's primarily what a cache is
offering is that unused space to people
but the point where they can maximize
the value of what they've already they
invested in the in the in the in the
data center itself and all the hardware
all the hardware all the space Etc and
if it's not being actively used by a
client that that they have a contract
with and they've got 50 of it available
they can make it available to the
network and for limited periods of time
it can get being rented constantly and
they can maximize the income that they
get from their Hardware it's like a
company builds a building and only
inhabits 30 or 40 percent of salaries
and rents out the others and as it grows
it takes over those floors so it's lots
of space in future use that could be
exactly brought in online now and that
same thing applies when it comes comes
to training AI networks these large
language model networks they require
they have a phase sorry let me just
finish your thoughts so instead of
needing you know your VC to get you
access to the gpus that you need or
having to figure out how to buy them you
know let's say that there's a some
developers who just want to like
bootstrap themselves they have the
skills to build they don't want to go
the route of investment they just want
to build something cool they can get
access to the gpus that they need at a
much more affordable price through these
rental markets and they can use it just
for the period of time that they need to
do their training and then not have that
you know the financial overlay of having
bought the machines themselves and then
sitting on a shelf after they're done
with the training they can just rent it
for the period that they need for the
for the training and then it moves on to
the next customer so they're renting it
remotely
so both the person who put in the money
to buy it is able to maximize the value
of having bought it because they're
constantly getting rental income from
doing so and the person who just wants
access to the training doesn't have to
buy the hardware to do so yeah this is
what markets are great at right yes
exactly how to take the residual and
turn it into a project efficiency
exactly yeah exactly
but the other way that it makes AI safer
is by being able to verify the training
models that are used by keeping a kind
of like transparent record of those
right there's one two different ways
there's
um there's something called zkml zero
knowledge machine learning that I don't
know the details of it yet I've just
kind of glanced over it a little bit um
but zero knowledge itself has been
around for a little while there's
there's zcash and a handful of other uh
cryptocurrency it's basically just
trying to maintain privacy so that not
all of your transactions are public to
everyone but it's still verifiable so
that's that's really huge and what zkml
lets you do is say look at the output of
something and you can verify that it
came from a particular training model
and a particular set of training data
and then the other thing that you can do
to increase that value is make sure that
the training data itself is public most
training data that most of these models
are trained on are proprietary uh and
and it's part of their walls around you
know it's their moat
um but it's an important part of their
business it's like one of the real
dangers with AI is if your model gets
out right like that's your proprietary
information exactly yeah so but the
whole Collective has a lot more
incentive to share that to share access
to that data than these few things and
there's there's no actual mode around it
aside from you need data and then you
need to to tag that data and collect it
all together and then apply it to a
training model so storing that data on a
permanent public file storage system
like are we for example especially are
we've because it has the ability to tag
every single piece of data that goes
into it makes it a perfect repository
for for training data because you can
say at this point in time this is the
training data everyone can audit it
everyone can look at it and and then we
apply zkml on the other side we know
what went in we know what the the model
that was used to train and then we can
trust the actual output
um it is apparent to me
that these models are going to have so
presumably every model everybody who
owns an llm that is trained on a data
set has a complete record of the data
set
possibly some point
the problem is the data set is going to
be common I know this is already
partially an issue but is going to
become a live phenomenon in other words
exactly that's what I'm describing go
read up on a topic upon being queried is
a different object
it seems to me an absolute requirement
that a record of everything that was
processed be maintained and an ability
for a court for example let's say that
an llm commits a serious crime
we need to be able to figure out what
you know if there's a serious crime that
has been committed by several llms what
is it that they processed that caused
them to engage in this that's an
important question and as long as it's
proprietary we don't know which we don't
know and right it's like the hidden
stuff inside of Pharma yeah yeah but one
of the things that's really exciting
here is you know web 2
proprietary stocks really had the
advantage they were able to make it so
sleek and easy to use and you know kind
of like Apple products where like you
can't you know you have to jailbreak
them to get into them because they want
to be so easy to use right that
proprietary aspect was an advantage
and open source is like slow and clunky
and you know awkward and there's just
difficult to kind of it's like hurting
cats right open source software
development up until this point what's
exciting here is that with AI open
source really has the advantage because
each model can kind of train the next
right and you can use it as this kind of
like virtuous
spiral
positively to make the models better and
better and better well that and also one
of the ways that closed Source was able
to maintain its moat is that you write
your code and then you compile it and
what's available is the binary the
compiled binary and like you pointed out
earlier people can't read that well
guess what llms can they can reverse
engineer compiled binary back to the
original source so it's almost pointless
to try to close your Source you're not
protecting anything there's licenses but
that just requires legal enforcement
which has always been the case but
practically and realistically you can't
protect your code anymore just by
compiling it these machines will be able
to already can most code you know take
apart and and reconstruct it eventually
it's gonna be able to do all of it
yes so we are once again running up
against the
failure
of those who wrote the laws and the
Constitution being able to anticipate
what technology would do with any of
these things right the fact is uh you
know you can see the frightening
predicament of
uh people who have spent a lifetime
learning to generate software code
if an llm can instantly decode whatever
you've done from the the from the binary
and learn from it and improve on it and
you know all of your investment has just
trained in llm in you know seconds
um
on the other hand the llms are reading
all of us you know all the stuff that we
went to graduate school to figure out
how to think our way through and it's
going to be able to reverse engineer
that very quickly and you know are we
entitled to the benefit of what we
figured out if an llm then reads it and
repeats it in language it doesn't sound
like us you know that's uh
so anyway we're in a break that's
exactly why I said earlier that you
should have your own personal AI agent
because then you do get the benefit of
all those things if you're only thinking
of AI as adversarial that someone else
is running it and you have to be on the
lookout for it yes that's a lot more
dystopian you know future if you have
your own agent that you know is running
on Hardware that you trust that was
trained by models that you are have some
amount of awareness over understanding
of and it's its instructions are to try
or to to assist you and it learns your
patterns and it knows what you need and
everything like that it can help you
detect fakes it can help you uh uh you
know and help you in a number in a
number of important ways
well I mean I as I think you know my
concern is the number you know yes it
could definitely be very very helpful
and it can also be really destructive a
world of people who have personal llms
uh doing their bidding online is a world
none of us have ever seen and I
guarantee you that the horrors that we
have not yet contemplated that arise
from that world is
um going to be
uh it's going to be a very surprising
place to find ourselves so I agree but I
also think that the Beauties and the
inventions and the creativity and the
incredible advancements that will make
in that world will outstrip it and there
are more good people than there are bad
people and these are just tools just
like fire bicycle for the Mind any
bicycle for the mind it can be used for
good it can can be used for bad and
that's that's that is the most
compelling reason in my opinion that
these things need to be open source is
that we all need access to them and when
Devin says you know you can trust it you
can verify it
I often hear when he says that I don't
have the tools to do that I don't I
don't have the technical capability to
do that and what you need to just like
put in in your mind is like well I can
proxy that to someone I do trust whether
that's an institution that stands up to
say like we are verifying these things
and giving them our stamp of approval or
it's your partner who does have those
tools or your friend or or however it is
that you go about trying to you know
determine that for yourself the the open
source nature of it is
is how we combat that danger that you're
talking about
every single time a a technology of this
degree of power and this much of an
increase comes around it's scary like
the the compute the internet itself the
computer before that electricity before
that and go way back the harnessing of
fire they're dangerous they have the
potential to harm they're very scary but
that every single one of them has
leveled us up enormously the ability to
harness fire meant we could eat meat
meant our brain screw meant we I think
you definitely would know this that it
took us from the last form of ourselves
into our current form of ourselves and
that's rather significant electricity
enormously lifted us up the internet
lifted us up all those things so they
were always scary
and yet they didn't end the world not a
single one of them infected and they and
they in fact always increased the uh
health wealth Wellness length of Life
the productivity the creativity Etc of
humankind
and I think this is no different
um yeah unfortunately there's a sort of
a bit of magical thinking in there you
know I don't disagree that if you had an
infinitely large planet
and
you know
therefore indefinitely large segments of
it could go extinct and would be
repopulated by the others
we could guarantee that that's where we
would end up
unfortunately what we've got is
a an asymmetry between the utility
of the power that will come from AGI
to the unscrupulous versus those of us
who are normally constrained by morals
right and the problem is that even if
you have an equally powerful llm as some
uh Shameless person
that person can do more with it right
because there are things they will do
that you will not so what has to be true
you're of course right Amy the there are
more decent people than there are
terrible people but the disproportionate
power that terrible people will get from
this leverageable technology is
something that we have to be concerned
with and this is of course why
the law exists
right what you need to do is take the
advantage that unscrupulous people have
and neutralize it by delivering a
penalty that exceeds the benefit that
they can get right that's the
fundamental element of it's how we can
have Society punishment exactly and the
problem is we don't have laws that are
adequate to this moment we don't have
you know we have corrupt people
governing us so they're not in a
position to deliver us the enlightened
laws that we might need and yes and no
but anything that they could use it to
to harm you with is almost certainly
already illegal
um so it's a matter of enforcement it's
a matter of detection not really good
old criminology uh if an llm
reads
content generated by thoughtful people
who've invested in understanding the
world
generates a model of how their mind
works and then delivers a
book to its owner as if written by some
other person who did not consent to
being
exploited in this way and the owner of
this llm publishes this book and because
it's full of enlightened things uh
becomes wealthy and renowned from it
it's not illegal as far as I know
certainly immoral
um but I mean you could make a case that
it has wire fraud like we've got a lot
of laws
and so you find the right one that falls
just right into it and you can in fact
prosecute some Behavior like that that
isn't explicitly defined but I think
that there is undoubtedly danger that
blooms ahead of us you know especially
um as we're making the transition right
we talked about how Devin was a
compositor and he could make images that
didn't exist 20 years ago well
we've we've developed that
skepticism over this period of time
right to be aware like is this image
real is it not real was it made by you
know how is it made and so as this
technology rolls out there that period
of time during the rollout I think
people are much more vulnerable than
they are on the other side and so you
know
um being you know skeptical
um is is important during that period of
time for sure
and I also think that uh part of what
you're pointing at is what you don't
want to be is lagging behind right right
100 things are going to be leveraging
this stuff for more and what you want to
do is make sure that you're well
protected until we figure out how to
manage this stuff and we will do that is
by leveraging Technologies such as uh a
blockchain ledger to establish the
authenticity or lack of authenticity for
uh pieces of evidence for example yep
exactly and on that note I think it's
important to say that that's a big part
of why it's important for the US to make
a clear legal path for entrepreneurs to
be building these systems because right
now those waters are very murky and I
can say from my own experience that
entrepreneurship is
fraught enough as it is without you know
the looming danger of the SEC coming
after you or something along those lines
through a kind of Regulation through
enforcement action years after you've
built something and people are using it
you're familiar with what happened to
lbr why I'm sure and so
um because we are in this competitive
landscape of
we need these tools to be used for good
right we need lots of people building
them so that we ultimately end up with
the best option and so that they are
used for good and we know already that
in some ways China is ahead of us in
building a system that would be used for
much more
authoritarian control of what of what
can be said social credit scores all of
that kinds of thing and so if
if they are allowed to get ahead of us
if we're not allowed to build and
they're already ahead of us that that to
me is a very very real danger that we're
looking at right now because you have to
wonder what the example I was giving
earlier about England and Germany and
the car England and Germany got into two
world wars within the next 50 years
after that and you have to have you have
to wonder at least to some degree did
that 30-year Head Start that England
game gave Germany have any impact on
that like this stuff isn't just about
technology geopolitical events spring
forth from who has a technological
advantage over someone else so if we all
put the brakes on on web3 and AI
development and the Chinese Communist
party doesn't because they see ways that
they can use this stuff to increase the
degree of control they have over their
own population that's going to harm us
dramatically
oh I'm no fan of the idea of a pause the
horses are already out of the barn and
the paws exactly things worse and not
better it will there's there's no
logical argument I've not heard a
logical argument for the pause yeah I I
I'm I'm definitely against it though I
have no shortage of concerns about the
the AI era and what what it's going to
look like
um I did want to suggest a couple things
get your take on them
um one is I don't trust governmental
authorities to be able to regulate this
environment without making it worse I
think they're almost certain to make it
worse both due to ineptitude and
Corruption and so I'm not eager for that
solution
even though I would with a a quality
government but
what about the idea that enlightened
members of this community whatever it is
could generate a
checklist of
uh sanctioned
behaviors and objectives and forbidden
behaviors and objectives and that
those involved could either
sign on to this
and then be monitored by others in that
Community or not sign on to it and that
we could look then as members you know
it's a little bit like the idea of I
don't really need the food I eat to be
certified organic by the government but
it's nice to be able to go talk to the
farmer and say you know is this
uncertified organic did you spray it
right right or are you doing are you
doing informally what I need you to be
doing and I'm not so worried about the
surcharge that comes from the
governmental
there's paperwork there's a for the
Fantastic example of exactly what you're
talking about that I think it's
hydroponic hydroponic can't be labeled
as organic because it's not in soil and
the way the law was specifically written
is it has to be in soil and hydroponic
can make much healthier food but Farmers
that want to make the healthiest food
are disincentivized from growing it that
way because they cannot label it as
organic and so you're totally right that
even with best of intention
having two strict of rules based around
words that can change their meaning over
time can definitely be dangerous and
honestly the problem we're up against
right now is we're already in that vote
that the Securities Law is written 100
years ago are just loose enough and then
the way that the courts have interpreted
them are just loose enough that some of
these things overtly look like
Securities for short but some of them
don't especially the kind of stuff that
we're talking about decentralized but
there's a sub sector that's called
decentralized physical infrastructure
networks or d-pin that really have to do
with there is some utility that you're
getting from it it's not just a
financial service yeah you have to pay
for it but I have to pay for AWS and
that doesn't make it a financial service
so taking away the fact that you have to
pay for it the point is it creates some
utility it runs something those should
not be treated like financial services
and unfortunately because of the lack of
newly written legislation since this
stuff has come out what Amy mentioned
earlier is that the SEC has had a policy
of
enforcement like that they they dictate
what the new rules are just by putting
out enforcement actions and going after
people and we're just supposed to back
interpret from there so I think
especially in the US and in a number of
other countries it's necessary to have
some amount of revision just to define
the lines a little bit more clearly like
some of these things are Commodities
some of these things are are securities
and some of these things might be a
third category that has never been
previously imagined and should be
treated differently and without those
things
a honest entrepreneur that has a great
idea for a new protocol for how to solve
a particular problem and wants to
bootstrap that by raising funds from the
the audience that's already interested
in that it's dangerous to do so in the
United States because there's there's a
high degree of Reason especially even
though we have something you know the
jobs Act was passed I think 10 years ago
where its purpose was to say
um uh crowdfunding Network crowdfunding
systems should be able to crowdfund
based on just a share of something and
not just an object that's being released
so if there's a million tokens that get
released 10 of them get set aside for
the crowdfunders that help bootstrap it
for me help me actually raise the money
to build the thing that's a good way to
go about developing a new thing but it's
almost certainly illegal in the US
despite the jobs act and despite that a
lot of lawmakers want this stuff to be
legal in the U.S so fortunately I I I I
feel a little bit more optimistic about
it because the people that are currently
in charge uh of the um the house
Financial Services committee the the
current share is one of bitcoin's
biggest fans he said like five years ago
he said Bitcoin is an Unstoppable Force
everyone that's tried has failed like he
gets it we've had a number of half of
our job is talking to these lawmakers
and especially their staffs and they get
it a lot of people in in Congress right
now really do deeply understand it and
thank goodness for that because they are
crafting things that we think could
actually solve this problem but the
truth is even if they mess it up it's
just like the German and England German
and English thing this is a worldwide
technology someone there's a number of
other countries in the world England
throughout the EU they're passing all
kinds of laws that make it safe to
actually build a business on this
technology because they want to pull in
some of that you know Financial activity
and stuff like that
um and so if we're out competed we're
going to catch up so I hope that we
don't go through a period of them
messing it up and we end up with you
can't grow Hydroponics and call it
organic and someone else does and proves
the model and shows just how beneficial
it can be and so we have to then catch
up I hope we don't go that route it's
possible but even in worst case scenario
we can go that route by learning after
the fact well but you're talking about
the the legal side and and Brett you're
really asking about kind of like a self
a self regulation and how can the
industry engage in that and that is in
the midst of being worked out I would
say there are
so you know the w3c sir Tim berners-lee
started it in the 90s alongside the
world in order to
um provide recommendations for how to
use the web standard and how the web
standard should grow and change over
time so that the different parties that
were using it could weigh in about what
their needs are and we're looking at
that same kind of thing today where you
know there's a specification being
created for decentralized identity
so that that issue of who I am across
platforms can be worked out so that it's
interoperable rather than platform
specific and those standards are kind of
being hashed out and there's different
protocols that are gathering around
certain standards there's protocols that
are inventing their own standards and
trying you know they're kind of out
there by themselves and so that's
something that we're kind of just in the
midst of working out right now but when
it comes to that um
that self-enforcement of that of those
ideas or that ethos that you create
that's something
um that is
different because of that level of
transparency that we've talked about
because the authenticity that these
networks provide that can be analyzed
differently that can be sort of more
available as these problems are being
solved but the the answers aren't fully
there yet is the honest truth it's
something that the industry the web 3
Industry is very aware of and is like an
active kind of conversation about how do
we sort of self-regulate to make sure
that things are going in the best
Direction
um but the the absence of Regulation at
the federal level is like harming that
conversation from proceeding because
we're not sure fully like what we even
can do yet in terms of building these
protocols in some ways I get
essentialist autonomous organization
might be a way to actually solve that
where all the stakeholders can prove
that their vote came from them using
cryptographic security and a blockchain
to record all the votes but launching
one could be treated as a security and
thus it's not safe to do so and how do
you even launch one if
and or some sort of entity
to be
is connected to for tap it it's it's a
difficult road right now
um but the and one of the big issues
that we will be facing as we walk that
road is governance because these
protocols may change over time as needs
change and how those changes are decided
is going to be really really important
so we're going to see a lot of different
kind of experiments in governance
experiments in governance and from that
hopefully you know hopefully we get it
right right yeah yeah
I mean I guess I was
uh we're sort of blurring the
distinction here between web3 and uh AI
special intelligence obviously there's a
relationship here they are going to
emerge in tandem
but I'm concerned
um about the asymmetry that comes from
artificial intelligence
the ability to leverage it more
powerfully if you have all options open
rather than a moral constraint and that
the solution
one solution is for those who are
developing these things to self-certify
uh adherence to a set of rules and and
values and what I what I don't know is
what would be on that list is it
plausible to you that a you know if I go
to the farmer and I say you know did you
spray these things and they say no then
I know something right is it possible to
spell out what the uh the guidelines are
that that we would want honorable
developers to adhere to
so that there could then be you know a
if somebody
self-certified and then violates the
parameters that that would be understood
to be a serious problem is it possible
to generate that list and
um for it to carry any weight
I think so I think I think that's one of
the things that one of one of the
Technologies you mentioned earlier zkml
or zero knowledge machine learning
um can be a part of
um because right now it's kind of a
black box the output you get you don't
necessarily know one what the training
model was or two what the training data
was that fed into giving you that output
and if your output is some way to
manipulate someone then very likely
either
the training data itself the training
model itself or the prompt that was used
to generate the output includes some
instructions to do illicit behavior in
some way and without the transparency of
knowing you have you don't know zkml and
publicly stored training data give you
the ability to actually have that
transparency and so I think it creates
the opportunity because
there isn't necessarily an incentive to
do these things in public unless you
want that for the scalability you want
the collective action to it and also you
want to be able to be a signatory onto
that letter saying we're only going to
use this for good we're never going to
intentionally use it to harm other
people one of the ways that you can
validate that you're a signatory on that
is that you're using public training
data and that your models are are
transparent using Technologies like ckml
so I I uh
I'm beginning to see a connection to
some other disasters that we have
encountered in recent history
where if you if we look at
um the financial collapse of 2008 the
Fukushima disaster the Deepwater Horizon
explosion
um the Aliso Canyon disaster
covid if we look at all of these things
we see the same pattern where
competition produced the ability to do
something technologically that outpaced
our ability to undo it right and that in
each of these cases
what you needed was the pace of
development to be slowed down so that
the corrective action was uh was able to
keep a magnitude right if you if you if
you can't plug a hole at the bottom of
the ocean you shouldn't be drilling a
well at that depth right that sort of
thing right
um
the problem that I think I'm now pretty
sure we're going to face in the land of
AGI is
we are going to be driven by competition
to develop AGI as rapidly as possible
and the ability to control AGI will lag
and so
there's a disaster that we don't need to
face if we could agree to
a symmetry between the power of the AGI
and the power to control the AGI but of
course we can't for the game theory
because it's a global technology right
limit our own agis then the CCP will
generate them faster Etc so that's
really right the question that has to be
addressed
but
which is a way I continue to believe
that the answer to that is that it needs
to be as open as possible right me too
so that everyone has access to the
latest developments and that the
developments being done in public
because then
I I tend to believe that any that that
asymmetry is defeated by the
collectiveness that if everyone has
access to their own and there's one bad
actor that's trying to abuse their own
proprietary one it's going to be
defeated by the collective action of
everyone having access to their own of
equal power and if you put a thousand of
an equal power thing with one well that
thousand Collective is definitely more
powerful than the one
yeah although uh let's take an example
of where a rational limit might be uh
imposed okay
it seems to me that looking at the sum
total of the data that the llm read
is actually a lossy kind of compression
and that what you really want to be able
to do is recreate the state of the llm
upon each new ingestion of data right
for everything it reads it changes a
little
and you want to be able to say well what
if I had asked this query and then pick
any moment sort of the way the Wayback
machine lets you go and say well what
was the state of the web on this hour of
this day right you can do that you can
do that because a trained model is a
state
and if those states are stored in
something like rweave which is a
permanent file storage system it's
hashed and time stamped and you know
exactly when it existed at that point
with each article it reads you get an
update
no because you wouldn't want you because
you're not going to rerun all the
training because of the cost of the the
compute power to rerun the training so
they're only going to rerun the training
every so often that's not quite the same
as when it's ingesting a new article
there's different variations of that but
right now for example gpt4 has not just
the training data that it got up until
2021 but it has a connection to Bing so
we can search the web but that's not new
training data that's part of a prompt so
it takes its overall training data and
it's kind of a a kind of a twisted
version of a prompt of saying it takes
my prompt and it also says do these
reproducible things I.E browse the web
look for this search term
and then
put those two sets of data together and
then give me an output and all of that
could be stored so that every query is
stored in a way that's reproducible sure
no I I get that but it seems to me that
you want to have you know and I
understand I mean this is exactly why I
raise it this way it would slow down
training quite a bit if you had to
maintain each of these individual states
rather than say go read all these things
and come back and be an llm you know
um yes and no I mean it depends it
depends on how you're doing it if again
if it's an open Collective thing then I
might retrain the model that I'm using
once a month because there's a cost to
training you have to get access to those
incredibly expensive gpus to do it and
so because there's a cost that's a
constraint you're not going to do it all
that often you're going to do it at
whatever rate you want to the collective
can do it more often because the
collective has access to more gpus and
more resources and so if there's an open
model where everyone's paying a
subscription to have access to it and of
ten dollars worth of cryptocurrency that
goes into it decentralized autonomous
organization and trains whenever that
pot has raised high enough to pay for
the rental of the gpus needed to spend a
week doing the training then it's going
to do it at that rate and there'll be a
hash of the output at that point and
we're going to always have a provable
version of the state
and you can only do that with an open
model in my I mean you can only you can
do that most reliably and most
effectively and most efficiently with an
open model
yeah I mean I still see a lossy kind of
compression but um
to me I don't know how much it would
slow things down if you did have to
store all of these intermediate States
but
um I do you know the scientist in me
knows that there would be a tremendous
amount of value and being able to
understand how it is that a particular
state of the Ultimate model was
generated if you could go back and you
could say this is the point at which it
began to make this changed yes yes well
you don't necessarily even need to store
the entire State you can if you're
constantly adding your training data to
this permanently stored thing what you
can do is you can just store a hash of
the state and so it's not very large
it's tiny but it's provable to that
particular version of the state and then
so it can evolve over time and you can
say at these different time stamps we
recorded a version of it and hashed it
and so now we've got cryptographic proof
or really mathematical proof that it is
what we claim it to be without having to
store a new set of it each time but
could you go back to any of those houses
yeah I think so yeah and there would be
a lot of value in that but it's exactly
the kind of thing that the market will
force us not to do
um I mean it because the API version of
the market where uh open API I mean open
AI is getting 20 bucks a month from
everyone that wants to be a power user
of this thing they have no incentive to
do it I totally agree
anyone that is working on an open source
version of this and there's so many more
entities that have to gain by sharing
their resources on having an open
version of it then the one entity open
Ai and Microsoft behind them or even you
know Google's obviously doing this
there's a handful of companies that are
trying to do this but they know there's
actually been internal uh notes from
Google leaked they know they don't have
a moat they can't actually prevent open
source from beating them and they know
that open versions of this are going to
be more powerful so there's only a
limited period of time here we're really
beholden to a few uh proprietary
instances of this but there's the
problem is there's a perverse incentive
I think in terms of
let's say that you are going to have
your your llm
read a bunch of
technical writing in a particular area
and then it was going to do some
inventing on your behalf and you were
going to monetize those inventions
you're going to patent them
and somebody wants to sue you and say
actually what you're doing is you're
taking my IP and you're you're
sanitizing it with your llm and then
you're going to go profit where in fact
I was entitled to and the fact is you
don't pause around private ownership on
this stuff yeah they're insufficient I
totally agree yeah so someone actually
just pointed out that maybe section 230
doesn't actually cover the outputs of
these things because it's not the
content generated by their users
necessarily it's the content generated
by a chatbot that's run by that company
itself so I totally agree the laws
around private ownership and how that
impacts this stuff are insufficient
currently they're insufficient but if
you had a
you know uncertified organic right we
agree to stay to store these states so
that you can recover the intermediate
and discover that this you know reading
this thing enabled it to invent X and
therefore you know so you could
self-enforce such a thing but I think
absent
a recognition that one needs such an
agreement
uh the market will drive people
to um
as a matter of self-preservation to
destroy the intermediate evidence of how
their model got it will to some I agree
some part of it will but there's also
opportunities to monetize your writing
like in the sense that I write a blog
post that has some insights into it and
just reading that blog post isn't worth
monetizing I'm not going to charge
people money for it but I can attach a
license to it and attach that license in
an atomic way so that it can't be
separated from it so if you were then to
look at the age at the output of the and
figure out oh is specifically reading
this blog that gave in the Insight
necessary to come up with this invention
well the license attached to that blog
was that I'll share 50 50 with anyone
that uses this data to come up with
something new I'll share 50 of the value
of that or my license might say I won't
share it I own it which might tell those
models avoid that because that would be
bad because right now the problem you're
talking about is just the fact that it's
like 97 of the web is license ambiguous
just right because the web doesn't have
a format to attach license to content
whether that's videos or music or
whatever else and so walled Gardens had
to build up around it in order to
protect that distribution and enforce
those licenses but it's obviously not it
isn't working in the current web 2 world
it's definitely not going to work in the
generative Ai and like what about the
model who the the woman the model whose
photo is being used very often in a lot
of these things in generative AI
shouldn't she get paid extra for that
again that's about licensing and so
there's a handful of entities that are
that are working on solving this what's
the name of the the the open licensing
uh what is it called oh Creative Commons
Creative Commons has been incentivized
to try to solve these kind of problems
for a long time and they are working
with web3 protocols and web3 startups to
come up with the new licenses that have
never been envisioned before and then
put it on a permanent information
storage and now you can attach the piece
of creative content that I generated to
a license that envisions it being reused
by someone else in the future and so you
have for example um what's her name uh
elon's baby mama
Grimes Grimes exactly she's openly
declared there is no license for this
but her just saying it on Twitter
becomes a license where she says use my
voice use my the whole history of my
music and invent new things and I'll
split it with you it's brilliant because
that's gonna be successful and and new
money is going to be made by that and
it's going to incentivize other people
to say I like this idea I'm going to try
this idea yeah but uh we need some new
architecture because let's say that I
put your I'll split it with you 50 50 on
some piece of writing
um a you need to be able to you know I
could put that on a trivial piece of
writing an llm could read it it could
have no effect on its state and I could
claim 50 ownership of something so we
have to be able to go back and prove
that it didn't have a material impact on
what we invented
agreed but so okay if you do go back and
you store those intermediate States so
that we can prove that my thing actually
enabled you what if 25 things which
offered to share 50 you know 50 50 with
you had a material impact on what you
ultimately produced right and then you
know so that's the license they're gonna
have to take that into account I agree
yeah licenses are going to have to be
you know
smart and we're going to have to have a
legal structure that allows you to
navigate these things and I wonder if a
smart working group couldn't put
together a
formalizable
you know perspectives on these kinds of
things and people could either sign up
for it or
amend it propose propose alternative
options kind of thing yeah that's a good
idea
um one of the things that got me just
into this space to begin with was how
profound of an effect this is going to
have for Content creators to be able to
monetize their content and
have access to their audiences and so
you know the the element of how AI will
affect that isn't honestly something I
thought very deeply about but the way
that web 3 is going to change the game
for Content creators is incredible and
will be extremely helpful to content
creators like you who are concerned or
have experienced you know being
demonetized are concerned about
censorship have been de-platformed that
kind of thing because you have a direct
relationship with your audience and they
can pay in a frictionless way that feels
like it does right now where there's a
subscription and yet micropayments are
are behind the scenes flowing to you and
to other people that you might recommend
their content and that kind of thing so
I want you to to flesh that out a bit
because this is in fact the conversation
that our friendship started around and I
was uh very struck by the picture you
painted of the world we were headed
towards and I'm a little surprised that
it has not emerged I am disappointed
that it has not emerged yet too exactly
exactly yeah but do you want to describe
if if you were um you know
building the protocols into the proper
stack what world would we be living in
and how would it work for uh creators
and influencers and uh you know yeah
absolutely we've actually been working
um with on a project that Ian Crossing
started you know Tim pool in Crosslands
um we called it Speakeasy because you
know
speech I think it has a new name since
then I don't remember okay
um but the the way that it works so you
know Tim Poole's content was like the
you know we were building it around that
so I'll just use that as an example
right so he has different guests on his
show on a regular basis who also create
content so let's say that he's putting
up his content
um and he's attaching a license to it
that says you know it costs whatever
amount to for a single play
um and that you and I have a browser
extension that we've installed that will
just we we pay a subscription to on a
regular basis like once a month we pay
five dollars and then behind the scenes
that browser extension pays every time
we click play to Tim pool for his
content well he could also have a
section where he's recommending other
creators and those creators in their
terms could say well any platform that's
Distributing this for me and it results
in a sale they can get a cut it could be
a flat fee it could be a percentage it
could be something else entirely the
terms of the contractor completely you
know able to be customized such that
they could even
you know accommodate those like music
weird edge cases you know music
contracts that are in existence now or
written 100 years ago and so they're
really complex and crazy but it could
even accommodate that so anyway the
point being so let's say you know
um there that there's a guest you you go
on his podcast and he wants to recommend
your content and you have your content
published in the same way so that it
says you know your content is let's just
use some easy numbers it's a penny per
play and or a buck to download so if I
want to watch it 100 times I pay a buck
and I've just got it but if someone's
just watching it once they pay a penny
sure
um so but you know if if they're viewing
it through Tim's website because he's
recommended it on his website or he puts
it in a social Channel and he's
recommended it that way that a portion
of that sale will go to Tim and a
portion of it will go to you and let's
say you know you have a producer even
that you are also sharing those revenues
with that that would automatically get
sent to them and as well and it wouldn't
happen after the fact like with license
like with
um uh music distribution with royalties
and stuff like that it would happen when
the transaction happens it's one of the
reasons that smart contracts are great
because you build smart contracts on top
of a a a payment platform and it means I
pay that one penny and it looks at the
Smart contract the smart contract says
okay I'm supposed to look at this
particular license and the license says
30 to this party 30 to the person that
recommended it and the rest to this and
it splits it right away and everyone
just gets the deposit right into their
wallet right away before the before the
person is even done watching the content
and it also you know has all of the same
the same parties we've been talking
about this whole time like like
transparency so that it can be audited
really easily you and I don't have to be
worried about you know somebody a third
party handling that split for us or you
know it's as you know somebody who
distributes on YouTube the
um it's very opaque the mechanism like
how you're paid how much you're paid why
you're paid all of that is extremely
opaque why you're certainly
demonetrating
job they're obviously making money from
the views that are that they're getting
because of your content that they've
decided you are not allowed to but then
let's take this a step further because a
lot of creators are like okay that
sounds cool but the friction here is
that I put out my content for free and I
rely on ads so what happens then and
then also the the kind of difficulty in
that is let's say you do put your
content on a platform like YouTube where
you don't control the ads that are being
shown on your uh on your content so you
know you're having this like very deep
conversation about the origin of life
and you know Evolution and all of that
kind of stuff and you have an ad play
that's like
about you know how uh that that
Evolution isn't real and you know
whatever it's like there's like that
right that friction that there that
things are incompatible you can't you
know you're somebody who's like talking
about
I don't know like intuitive eating and
then you have like a weight loss like ad
play on your you know on your content
and that kind of contrast is is a bad
fit for your audience well this the
layer that this also opens up is for
sort of creators to opt in to the kind
of advertising aggregators that would
make sense for them but this
infrastructure still all has to be built
there are definitely the pieces are
there the top layer hasn't been
assembled the tools are there yeah there
are definitely protocols working on ad
aggregator type services that would be
token based OD blockchain based in some
sort of way but that it's not built out
to the point where you could use it as a
viable alternative to using something
like YouTube and so that's definitely
um disappointing that it's taken so long
but it's definitely still something that
I think is potentially going to happen
the other aspect of it that you and I
have talked a lot about is the Game
Theory dynamics of how that gets going
because
um
in order for me to want to pay into a
subscription five dollars a month I need
access to the content that I want right
and if there aren't enough of the
creators that are using that same system
then I can't get that access to the
content that I want and so that chicken
and egg problem is something that hasn't
been figured out yet
yeah you have to jump into a network
somewhere that sees the potential in
this but I mean the potential is
absolutely huge yes much bigger than the
current market and and the potential
this is why I got excited about in the
first place because I have a background
in the Arts and I saw the crunch that
were creators were facing in the digital
distribution mechanism and how I like
creating sort of weird edgy art and it
made me super nervous to be
um you know essentially here like
sharecropping on these platforms like
you don't own the land you don't own
your audience you don't own anything
about it and you can be just
erased at any moment you know and have
invested years of work it's so tragic
and invested years of work to to be
making like barely a subsistence living
you know like the the amount of money
that that they're sharing with the
creators is so
out of balance at the amount of money
that they're making we did like a basic
calculation when we did
um an experiment with emotion Heap like
almost 10 years ago and so the average
uh she's a musician so the average user
listens to about 500 songs per month on
Spotify and if they were paying a penny
per play for those songs
two cents per play becomes the
equivalent to the Spotify ten dollars a
month yeah okay well that's that's what
it is in a penny per play the audience
pays 50 the audience pays five dollars
instead of ten and the Creator would
make seven to eight times what they're
currently making right now and so so
both sides would be benefited by this
obviously the economics for the creators
is like it makes it so that you can have
like a real sustainable living as a
Creator you don't have to be a rock star
or starve and frankly even rock stars
now have to tour to make money because
it's the only way left
for them to be making money because the
the the way that digital distribution
has changed the Dynamics and the econ
the economics of it has harmed artists
so much at this point yeah it's frozen
them out
um am I correct that it would also be
possible with this architecture to do
something like
let's say you generate a
photo manipulation programs you know uh
something that does what Photoshop does
or thereabouts
um and you could use you know micro
payments
instead of selling somebody a
subscription to it you could pay by the
hour for example or by the use like uh
newspapers like I hate the paywall the
subscription wall where it says like
right oh you've read the first few lines
of this you don't get to read the rest
unless you sign up for a monthly
subscription for 10 or 15 a month no I
would rather pay one penny for that one
use same exact thing yeah
um yes you totally could it can be
fractions of pennies because it's
cryptocurrency oh yeah it goes down to
10 decimal citizens yeah and it also is
is taking out the
the payment processor costs that you
incur in the current system the that
payment processor cost is so high that
you end up having to have a minimum
payment amount which then you're like
well I'm not going to pay a dollar to
watch this video or a dollar you know it
anyway yeah it just solves a lot of
those problems micropayments are
something that was theorized about at
the very beginning of the web there was
even like you know there's 404 is the
error code for you can't find something
402 I think was the code for a
micropayment you know it's just still
empty it just never made it there were
attempts at micropayments and like kind
of the
early Arts
um there were several big attempts at it
uh there were people that thought that
it was eminent
um but the problem that all of those
offerings at that time faced was that
there was some sort of centralized
entity that had to administer it there
was some point in the chain where it
wasn't fully transparent and so it
involved trust and that is the big you
know kind of innovation that Bitcoin
brought to the table which just changes
everything
so I a couple things one uh it'd be cool
and I don't see any obstacle to it you
could also if you you know put together
a Photoshop like program you could say
use is free but I get 20 of any profit
made on anything you do with this great
with it yeah and so lots of people would
use it never make a profit and they
would get the use for free but it would
be lucrative from the point of view of
the people who invested in building the
the program itself yep but it also
strikes me that this might be
this might be the use case that gets the
difficulty of crypto
low enough to get people
used to both
using crypto and collecting it right
because if the idea was let's say
Twitter
included a micro payment mechanism you
know you can make funny videos and you
can put them on your Twitter and people
can tip you or you can charge them five
cents if they want to look at it based
on your description or whatever
um and that you know in order to make it
tractable from Twitter's perspective
you know you you load
20 bucks in at a minimum and then you
spend it over whatever period of time it
takes to spend it and then you know
creators have to have some minimum
amount before they can extract it but
that anyway I guess the question is
would Twitter do it in dollars or would
Twitter require you to use crypto but if
Twitter required you to use
crypto then getting in on that economy
would be a good incentive for a lot of
people and the you know it's the minimum
complexity how do I get some crypto
then I spend it effortlessly with a
click and if I make some crypto how do I
get to something I can get it back out
right yeah and that takes us kind of
Full Circle back to the regulation
conversation because the reason that
platforms can't sell tokens directly to
users right now is because of ambiguity
around things like money service
business laws and blue sky laws where
because if if Twitter were to sell you
some tokens and then those tokens went
up in value because the the price of
that crypto is changing over time they
could then be liable to have to do some
reporting on you basically
um or the and that you would have to be
doing reporting as well and that just
makes the and they would be treated as a
money transmitter which has a whole lot
of extra loss that makes a danger too
high for them that that could be
something that they would be enforced
upon and so then that would work that's
why you have to go to those crypto
exchanges that you were talking about
that aren't the best experience and then
you have and so it just adds this layer
of friction any number of these
companies can sell their service direct
for credit cards so it's just like we
have carve outs for that and then we
have it carve outs for exchange
exchanges being able to sell money with
money but we don't have the ability for
that end point where it would be most
convenient for the end user to just use
a debit card to buy five bucks worth and
then use that constantly so it's just a
problem in terms of where we want to be
and and the obstacles to getting there
you know yeah but we're hoping that
they're they're working on that right
now actually
um Patrick McHenry like Devin was saying
he's Advanced two bills oh the market
structure bill and the stable coins bill
that are potentially moving forward
right now so you know things things are
hopefully moving in a positive direction
on that front
all right
um so before we close this discussion
out uh I fear I have cluttered the
discussion a bit uh because of my own
fears about Ai and uh you know
experiences with crypto and stuff like
that I'm wondering if you don't want to
paint the picture as you see it the web
um the web architecture that you're
hoping to Foster with your organization
and
um you know what problems it solves what
things remain uh after this you know
what's the stack of protocols and and
what do they do
sure
um okay
I would say for one thing it's less
Reliance on these giant corporations
like one of the things that web2 did was
it made the web easy to use by
centralizing around five or six big
companies and it was because they had
enough resources to build a really nice
Center interface and have enough
resources behind the scenes to make
things fast we can solve both those
problems in a decentralized way
especially if we also lean into AI where
the right inner you know YouTube's
interface is great in general for most
people but it's maybe not quite right
for everyone so one of the great things
that you can do is you've already solved
for the distribution problem that you've
got the the uh the storage is on
permanent file storage solutions or even
temporary file storage solutions so
you've got are we for permanent file
storage that's fully decentralized and
then ipfs for temporary file storage so
like chats and stuff like that that
don't need to be preserved forever but
it's also decentralized so you've you've
got the back end able to be solved for
and then you've got you know a cache is
a way that you can actually have
processes running in the back end and
stuff like that and then you can
actually have the front end generated on
the Fly for you you can say I want a
bigger you know play play screen and
less suggestions on the side or I only
want the suggestions that come from this
algorithm that I select or no algorithm
whatsoever I only want it to show me
subscriptions so it comes down to the
client and the end user themselves to
set their preferences for how those
algorithms should behave then there
becomes a market for algorithms because
people can actually license their
algorithms and say this one's really
great but I've figured out how to
innovate on it a little way a little bit
so certain types of people will enjoy
this one more and so you can subscribe
to mine for two cents a month and you'll
always get access to your feed in such a
way that I that that really works well
for you
you're able to do private Community
you're able to do like video
communication like this without having
to depend on Zoom which might be storing
this stuff as far as we know we have no
idea you could actually do it in a
private way using decentralized video
transcoding proc uh protocols like life
peer is one where primarily live peer is
used kind of as the back end for YouTube
we actually ran into this issue when we
were building Alexandria where uh you
could just upload a video and it would
play back right as it is and most people
because what they would upload is
something they downloaded from YouTube
it was already transcoded and ready to
be played for people but sometimes
someone would take an output like we
came across a filmmaker that wanted to
put trailers up for his movies and
whatever you export directly out of
Final Cut Pro or Premiere is generally
larger than the size of the file that
YouTube is serving up to because one of
the most important things that YouTube's
doing behind the scenes is it's
transcoding into multiple different
formats so that if you're watching it on
a mobile it's going to get a smaller one
if you're watching it on your 4K TV it's
going to be a larger one but you've got
you know the bandwidth to handle that
and if you don't have that it's going to
be an awful experience and we hadn't yet
implemented that into Alexandria so this
guy uploaded videos that were really
high uh bit rate and for the most part
you couldn't watch them without sitting
around and waiting so live peer is a
solution to that where it's using a
whole bunch of people's gpus in a
different way than training AIS and llms
it can be used for the actual
transcoding so it turns it into a bunch
of different formats and then it serves
up the right format for the right user
at each different point
um everyone that's creating content can
put it basically everywhere rather than
and not with a whole bunch of extra
effort where right now you know we we
create content and we have to put it
onto every different social media
Network and we also you know if we want
to put it into the decentralized space
we have to go to that individual one and
upload it there and we upload it to
Twitter and we upload it to YouTube and
to Instagram that's a lot of extra labor
it's valuable to us because it reaches a
larger audience so we want to do it but
we don't want the extra labor of it
whereas instead if it was just you put
it into a single permanent file storage
place and you attach a license to it
that says any front end that wants to
distribute this has the right to do so
as long as as I get paid x amount and
these are my terms and so then you can
have a variety of front ends both from
the centralized ones like YouTube or
even say Apple for example might have a
very specific threshold of saying we
need to get paid 30 percent otherwise we
won't do it so they get to filter on
their side of saying fine anyone that
doesn't want to offer up 30 gets
excluded anyone that does gets included
and then the individual front ends that
you have your you know AI generate for
you can include everything according to
the preferences that you set so now
we're enabling content creators to
maximize their possible audience because
they don't have to pick just the right
uh uh vertical to kind of publish into
they can just publish to the internet
itself and Discovery can be increased
because it's not going to be the
algorithm that was that was come up with
for the sake of benefiting YouTube
itself like YouTube's algorithms aren't
necessarily designed to benefit
individual content creators they're
designed to be like I just read recently
they they wanted to compete with Netflix
so they were trying to specifically lift
up 20 minute and longer content because
they wanted longer session times other
people came along and figured out well
it turns out if you make really short
three or four minute long videos and
they're compelling enough someone will
stick to it longer and so even though
the algorithm worked against them
initially the algorithm learned from
them maybe that might be better but the
point is it was designed for one company
for one company's benefits not
necessarily for the content creators
benefits if you have a market of
competing algorithms that anyone can
select for themselves which one serves
either Their audience their front end or
their particular content best then it's
going to get it to the right people like
Amy was talking about there's this
disconnect between your your content and
the ad that runs in front of it that
doesn't benefit you or The Advertiser
The Advertiser is less likely to be
clicked on so that that's that doesn't
make any sense it should in fact make
more sense so that it doesn't just
benefit who pays the most but who would
be the most likely the most benefited
party
so just to sum up what Devin said web3
re-decentralizes the web it pushes the
power to the ends of the network and in
so doing it empowers individuals to have
the experience that they want it allows
them to set their preferences it
empowers creators to reach their
audiences and to make more money
it empowers developers to build tools
that they weren't able to previously
build and it makes the tools that they
build more resilient to attack less
expensive to operate and and the reason
that they're less expensive is that
they're less resource intensive and so
they're they're for they're also more
efficient they're they're Greener
basically right they're more
environmentally friendly and so the the
kind of benefits that web3 gives us it's
that generational
upgrade that it's just better faster
cheaper in every possible way and most
importantly it restores the sovereignty
the transparency and potentially then
the trust that's been lost in the web
that we have today
that's great I see an analogy
you know back when I was a kid there
were things like hardware stores and
hardware stores were owned by people and
you know a family running a hardware
store might send their kids to college
on that income and then you know over
time it's all turned into Home Depot and
Ace and you know people are working
there and probably not sending their
kids to college and you know the person
at the top is you know has a very
impressive yacht no doubt but uh anyway
the the idea that there's some process
afoot in our economy that over time
freezes people out because it finds a
hundred ways to do that and the people
find themselves with less and less of a
stake basically just treading water
that's clearly happened on the web and I
love the idea that it was decentralized
it went through this period of
centralization and that web 3 is what
decentralizes it I would love to see
that happen
um the fact that it has an uh a benefit
with respect to AI is a huge bonus and
maybe that will be the
um the fire that gets lit under people
that yes inspires I think so to build
yeah
so that's that's quite a vision now
um I think I understood you to say
all the Technologies necessary to do
this exist the architecture that
integrates them is what's necessary is
that fair now architecture just the
killer apps
the apps
I mean you could say the architecture to
integrate them it's really just you know
there there are a number of different
um compute protocols there are a number
of different storage protocols storage
protocols video transcoding protocols
indexing protocols Etc and so what we
need now are developers to go and
experiment with them and put them
together in interesting ways and also to
build for those end users you know what
is that seamless experience that can
onboard
for billion people
yeah yep all right well
uh yeah I'm hopeful that that world can
emerge and that it will be a facilitator
of increased trust
um free exchange of ideas which is
obviously on the ropes that it will
deal the death now to centralized Bank
digital currencies
enable content creators to get paid for
what they're delivering to all of us all
of those things are were the objectives
in isolation and together it would be a
much a much better place so
uh I I thank you for laying out that
vision and for articulating how we might
get there and I look forward to seeing
um where this goes
where can people find you
uh we're on every social network at
web3wg and our website is uh at web3wg
and our YouTube channel is web3wg so
definitely we think they should come to
our website and sign up for our mailing
list so that if there are kind of
collective actions that we can all take
together we have access to reach out to
them to let them know that those things
are happening and then we put out most
of the kind of news that we follow on
Twitter and all the educational videos
that we make we do put out on YouTube
it's
web3wg.org just to mention that and I'm
personally at Amy of Alexandria
and I'm Devin or James at Twitter
awesome and your organization as we said
at the top is a 501c3 so presumably
people could uh don't it's a good cause
they would find that through your
website
sir exactly great all right well
um I hope that some people see this and
are inspired to help you guys out and
maybe people who uh have vision and own
important properties that could leverage
this Vision will reach out as well yeah
I was going to say it would be amazing
to hear from creators who are interested
in you know using these tools too
exactly all right great anything else
people should know
no thanks so much this has been a
delight yeah really fun to talk with you
it's been great I look forward to
checking in with you as things develop
sounds good all right be well everyone
bye thank you
[Music]